GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'D LIKE
TO CALL THE WEDNESDAY MAY SECOND
MEETING OF. BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE TO ORDER.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE ALL OF YOU HERE
I'M SURE THE DIES IS GOING TO
FILL UP EVENTUALLY BUT WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'M WE WILL WAIT.
I HAVE A TO VOTE ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR.
BUT.
.
I WILL ADVISE YOU ALL THAT
ISSUE NINETEEN IS GOING TO BE
PULLED FROM THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST OF FIVE.
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WE WILL. A AT THAT
TOO ITEMS TO BE HEARD WHEN WE
GET TO THE CALIFORNIA.
UTILITIES COMMISSION ITEM.
AND SORT FIRST ITEM TO BE HEARD
WILL BE.
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION.
WE HAVE ONE ISSUE INCREASED
LEASING COSTS ISSUE.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME.
I THINK IT'S ON.
THURMOND AFFECT I KNOW STONE
IT'S ON YELTSIN GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED I'M SUSAN ENHANCE
THE CHIEF DEPUTY OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST COMMISSION AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES AN
APARTMENT FINANCE. TO ADDRESS.
ARE.
STATE HEADQUARTERS OFFICE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE BEEN IN THE
LOCATION FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
OF THE LEASE IS UP IN OCTOBER.
AND THE RATES IN SEPTEMBER OF
LEASE RATES IN SAN FRANCISCO ARE
SOARING.
AND IS A VERY DIFFICULT.
CIRCUMSTANCE.
WE HAVE WORKED OUT WHAT WE
THINK IS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION WHICH IS TO STAY IN OUR
EXISTING LOCATIONS SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. MOVING COSTS.
WE ARE.
IN A LAST MINUTE KIND OF
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCE WITH
THE LANDLORD AND WE DON'T HAVE A
LEASE SIGNED YET.
SO THERE IS STILL A POSSIBILITY.
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER LOCATION. AND OTHER
LOCATIONS ARE ACTUALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT AND
WORKING WITH GENERAL SERVICES
AND WORKING WITH FINANCE ON
THAT.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT THIS
MOMENT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS SO ARE WE DO SUPPORT
THE RECOMMENDATION THAT. THAT
YOU HAVE AND THINK THAT THAT MAY
BE THAT. THE BEST THING TO DO IN
AND COME BACK TO YOU. IF.
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE.
ALRIGHT OF A THANK YOU.
AT ARE THE.
OPTIONS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ARE THEY ALL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE'VE LOOKED AT MULTIPLE OPTIONS
IN SERVICES GO WITH PARTNER
GENERAL SERVICES FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS AND MONTHS WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT OPTIONS.
AND THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
OPTIONS IN OAKLAND. THE THE
COMMISSION STATUTE REQUIRES THAT
THE HEADQUARTERS OFFICE BE IN A
COASTAL COUNTY OAKLAND IS NOT A
COSTA COUNTY.
BUT IT'S CLOSE ENOUGH TO MATCH
THE NEEDS OF BEING NEAR OUR
SISTER AGENCY THAT COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IN THE BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. WE DO ALL THE.
.
THE.
HR THE HUMAN RESOURCES WORK FOR
THE BC DC OUR STAFF DOES SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE AS CLOSE TO THEM
AS POSSIBLE. ALSO BEING IN A
COSTA COUNTY WHERE THERE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO GET TO THE LOCATION
ONE OF THE OVER ARCHING NEEDS WE
HAVE IS TO BE NEAR PUBLIC
TRANSIT. WE HAVE A HUNDRED
PERCENT COMPLIANCE OF EVERY
SINGLE PERSON ON OUR STAFF USES
PUBLIC TRANSIT OR WALKS OR TAKES
THEIR BIKE TO WORK EVERYDAY.
SO THAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ENOUGH UP A
TRANSIT CENTER AND ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET.
TO.
THE COMMISSION LOCATION
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES I'M
SEARCHING OUT POSSIBILITIES IN
OAKLAND WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A
STATUTE ADJUSTMENT TO.
BE ABLE TO BE LOCATED IN OAKLAND
THEY TOLD ME YESTERDAY THEY
DON'T THINK THE PRICES ARE MUCH
CHEAPER THERE BECAUSE THE SAME
BLOOM IS HAPPENING. IN THAT
LOCATION
SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS
DILIGENT AS AS REPEAT THIS
WEEKEND.
THANK YOU AYE I THINK A WE. ARE.
THE GIVEN THE.
SEVERITY THE HOUSING CRISIS WE
QUICKLY FORGET THAT.
IN SOME AREAS OTHERS SAID.
ABOUT A GROWING AFFORDABILITY
ISSUES SAW ON THE COMMERCIAL
SIDE
ON THE COMMERCIAL LEASING SIDE
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE FACING SOME
OF THAT BUT I.
I SUSPECT THAT.
HOUSING COSTS ARE ALSO A FACTOR.
OF FOR CONTINUING TO BE LOCATED
IN IN IN SAN FRANCISCO SINCE
THEY ARE. ON A SO HIGH IN THAT
AREA AND SURROUNDING AREAS.
I THINK MY PREFERENCE ACTUALLY
ON THIS ITEM WILL BE TO HOLD IT
OPEN SINCE THERE'S SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY. AND TO ASK YOU TO
SHARE SOME OF THE.
INFORMATION THAT YOU JUST
REFERRED TO AND IN GREATER
DETAIL WITH.
A WITH BUDGET STAFF SO SO THAT
TO A WE CAN HAVE A LOOK AT IT AS
AS AS WELL HAPPY TO DO THAT.
THE SUR LA OVER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HAVE ANY COMMENTS GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RYAN BROWN WITH LA NO.
WHO WITH REGARD TO THE
ORIGINALS BRING SECTION LETTER
OF OR EXCUSE ME?
FINANCE LETTER WE CAN HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WE THE WE GOT QUITE A
BIT OF INFORMATION FROM THE
COMMISSION ABOUT THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE THEY DID LOOKING FOR
DIFFERENT SITES CAN. THOUGH THIS
IS A VERY LARGE INCREASE IN THE
RAM WE THOUGHT WAS REASONABLE
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT GIVEN THAT CHANGE IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES NOW I I THINK
HOLDING IT OPEN THAT DOES MAKE
SENSE IN THE SHORT TERM.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM DYESS
WELCOME MR FONG.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
OUR NEXT ITEM ON THE ITEMS TO BE
HEARD IS THE. PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
WHEN WE HEAR FIRST FROM THE.
OFF THE RATE PAYER ADVOCATES.
AND THEN OUR NEXT ITEM WILL BE.
ISSUE NINETEEN THAT WAS PULLED
OFF OF THE VOTE ONLY COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING MS APPLES WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN LIMON MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH ACKLES
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF RATE
PAYER ADVOCATES AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
OR A.
THANK YOU FOR IT THE OPPORTUNITY
DISCUSS ORIS REQUEST TO UPDATE.
OUR NAME TO PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE.
AS YOU KNOW ONE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES IS FOR OVER A TO
COMMUNICATE MORE CLEARLY WITH
THE PUBLIC AND MAKE OUR
PROCESSES MORE TRANSPARENT. AND
ACCESSIBLE.
AS THE PUBLIC'S ADVOCATE IT IS
CRITICAL.
TO STRENGTHEN OUR CONNECTION
WITH THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
INFORMATION WASTE RECEIVED FROM
CUSTOMERS HELPS US TO FULFILL
OUR MISSION BY BUILDING A STRONG
CASE TO KEEP UTILITY SERVICES.
AS LOW.
AS POSSIBLE THE COSTS AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE CONSISTENT WITH SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY.
THROUGH OUR INTERACTIONS WITH
THE PUBLIC IT IS BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT OUR
CURRENT NAME DOES NOT RESONATE
WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CUSTOMERS ARE
CONFUSED BY THE TERM RATE PAYER.
THEY DON'T THINK OF THEMSELVES
AS RATE PAYERS
THEY PAY BILLS NOT RATES.
THE TERM RATE PAYER IS INSIDE
BASEBALL ITS TYPICALLY A TERM
USED ONLY BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
CLOSELY FOLLOW CPC ISSUES.
AND OUTSIDE OF THE CPC THAT TERM
IS RARELY IS CERTAINLY NOT WITH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
IN FACT OUT OF OVER FORTY ORI
EQUIVALENCE AROUND THE COUNTRY
ONLY TO STILL USE THE TERM RATE
PAYER.
MANY OF OUR COUNTERPARTS USE
THAT TERM.
PUBLIC SUCH AS PUBLIC ADVOCATE
OR PUBLIC COUNSEL.
CHANGING OUR NAME THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WOULD MAKE OUR
NAY MORE UNDERSTANDABLE TO THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE. AND MORE
ACCURATELY CONVEY OUR PUBLIC
INTEREST MISSION.
THIS STRAIGHTFORWARD NAME CHANGE
WILL NOT CHANGE OUR MISSION IT
WILL HELP US TO ACHIEVE OUR
MISSION.
AS THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THE SCOPE
OF OUR MISSION WILL BE CLEAR.
WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC IN COMMISSION PROCEEDINGS
AND RELATED FORUMS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR ABILITY TO
INTERACT AND LEARN FROM THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THEIR NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES WILL BE STRENGTHENED.
TOMORROW THE SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER TWO WILL
CONSIDER A STAFF RECOMMENDATION
TO ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO RENAME US AS IT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
THIS CHANGE WILL HAVE NO
ASSOCIATED BUDGET COSTS
THE LAST TIME OUR NAME WAS
CHANGED IT WAS ALSO DONE THROUGH
A TRAILER BILL.
THE SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT CHANGE
WILL UPDATE AND MODERNIZE OUR
NAME TO MAKE IT MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE THUS HELPING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CONNECTION TO THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
AS A PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
CONNECT WITH YOUR CONSTITUENCY
AND THAT WORDS MATTER IN MAKING
THAT CONNECTION.
BECAUSE THE NAME CHANGE WILL
HELP US TO ACHIEVE OUR MISSION
IT IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR ME.
TO SUM UP.
BECAUSE WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS THE
SIMPLEST MOST UNDERSTANDABLE
NAME FOR OUR OFFICE.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTIVELY
REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE TO APPROVE
CHANGING OUR NAME TO PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
I HOPE THAT WE CAN COUNT ON YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE.
I OF A VERY MUCH AGREE WITH YOU
THAT.
THAT THE TERM RATE PAYER IS.
NOT ONE THAT'S BROADLY
UNDERSTOOD BY THE PUBLIC.
MAN CAN LEAD TO SOME CONFUSION.
.
I'M NOT SO SURE THAT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE REALLY YOU
KNOW MAKES IT THAT MUCH CLEAR TO
THE PUBLIC. WHAT YOUR ACTUAL
MISSION AS?
BUT IT CLEARLY DOES TIE INTO
PUBLIC AND ADVOCACY AND I THINK
THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD POSITIVE.
WORDS ARE.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT THAT.
WHATEVER THE NAME IS IS THAT IT
TABBY CONNECTED TO THAT THE P.
YOU SEE. AND SO WHEN YOUR.
USING THIS NEW IDENTIFIERS
SOMEHOW GOING TO BE LINKED TO
CPUC.
YEAH I KNOW HOW YES IT IT IS WE
WILL WE ARE STILL AND ALWAYS
WILL LAUNCH INTO ALWAYS WILL
BECAUSE THAT'S IN YOUR HANDS
BUT.
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
RIGHT SO THAT THE OFFICE OF
REPAIR ADVOCATES.
IS BY STATUTE WITH IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE IF THE NAME OR CHANGE
WHAT ALSO SIT AT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. AND
ARE A CURRENTLY ARE OUR BUSINESS
CARDS ARE STATIONARY ON OUR
PRESS RELEASES ON EVEN THIS
AGENDA ITEM AT ALL IDENTIFIES US
AS CONNECTED TO THAT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION SO.
SO I THINK BY HAVING THIS OR
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
WHAT THAT SCOPE IS THAT WE WOULD
BE REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC IN.
COMMISSION PROCEEDINGS AND
RELATED FORUMS THAT IMPACT
UTILITY CUSTOMERS.
OKAY.
I IT'S A LITTLE BIT WORDY.
BUT I'M INCLINED TO THINK THAT
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AS
AN OFFICIAL NAME.
.
MIGHT MIGHT.
GET US CLOSER BUT I WANT TO GIVE
THIS SOME THOUGHT WE ALREADY
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO TO HOLD
OPEN.
WE WILL RESOLVE THIS BY THE END
OF THIS BUDGET CYCLE OF A MAKE
THAT COMMITMENT TO YOU. OF BUT I
DO THINK THAT CONNECTION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AUTUMN AND I COULD SEE A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE FUTURE
WHERE.
ONE MIGHT SHORTEN IT DOWN BUT
KEEPING THAT CONNECTIVITY.
FOR THE TIME BEING TO ME IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
AGAIN.
AYE I THINK A ONE HAVE ONE MORE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND THINK
ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT
I.
CAN GET CLOSER TO OF THE PLACE
WILL BE ABLE TO PUSH THIS
THROUGH. GREAT WELL THANK YOU I
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR EARS
THOUGHT THAT IS GOING INTO THAT
SAID MEANS A LOT TO ME NAY NAMES
ARE IMPORTANT YEAH.
THAT EIGHT THEY CONVEY A
MESSAGE AND.
.
I WANT TO.
HAVE PEOPLE THINK THE WRONG WAY
ABOUT THIS BUT YOU KNOW TO TO A
DEGREE THIS IS A A A MARKETING
ISSUE.
ADMIRAL MARKET YOURSELF IN THE
TRADITIONAL WAY THAT A FOR
PROFIT BUSINESSES DO BUT THE
IDENTIFICATION THAT YOU HAVE IS
THE WAY THAT THE. THE OF THE
MARKETPLACE UNDERSTANDS WHO YOU
ARE SO IT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE PUT A LOT OF THOUGHT INTO
THIS AND THAT YOUR TEAM. HAS PUT
A LOT OF THOUGHT INTO THIS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WITH
THE.
A WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE ASWELL
GIVING IT SOME THOUGHT WHAT WILL
THANK YOU I I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR EARS SINCE YEAR OF THOUGHTS
AND GOING INTO ALL THIS AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
TODAY SO THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE.
ABOUT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
HE HAD.
OR ELLIE OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALRIGHT I GUESS IT'S
JUST ME AND YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOM
THINKING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
THE ISSUE NINETEEN MILITARY
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT ENERGY
MEETING.
A METERING.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS WE HAVE THE.
MR MCKINLEY HERE FROM.
THE.
.
A MARINE CORPS INSTALLATIONS
WEST
YES SIR WELCOME SIR MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NET
MCKINLEY.
I'M WITH MARINE CORPS
INSTALLATIONS WEST TOWARD THE
PROPOSAL HERE. IS A TECHNICAL
FIX IN THE LAW. RIGHT NOW THE
LAW OF. A SEVERELY RESTRICTS
MILITARY BASE BEING ABLE TO USE
THE ANY IN TWO POINT OH TARIFF
THIS IS LIKE A GLITCH IN THE
STATUTE THERE'S NO REASON FOR
IT.
ALL THE PROPOSAL DO IS BRING
THIS INTO CONFORMANCE WITH EVERY
OTHER CUSTOMER GENERATOR.
GRANDEST PARITY WITH UC'S OR.
TRIBAL CASINO OR LARGE
INDUSTRIAL FACILITY.
IN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR THANK
YOU I HAVE NO QUESTIONS BUT I
THINK.
WE MET QUESTION FROM MISTER
PATTERSON NON.
RIGHT.
FONG.
I JUST QUESTION I IN TERMS OF
UP.
WOULD THIS BE WHY DID NOT THAT
DID WHY DID THIS PROPOSAL NOT GO
THROUGH THE.
HIT THE THE COMMITTEE A PROCESS
THAT MISTER MISTER PATTERSON
CHAIRS.
IN TERMS OF WE'RE GOING TO THE
BUDGET STEP.
POLICY COMMITTEE I JUST
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE P. YOU SEE
WITH THE BUDGET COMMITTEES.
THIS IS WHAT WHAT WAS PROPOSED
AYE I CAN ONLY ANSWER MORE THAN
THAT.
THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
MORE.
COMMENT FROM MY ALLEY OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MILLION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MORNING.
THIS IS THIS PROPOSAL IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THEREFORE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT AT THIS TIME.
HI.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE A.
WE'RE GONNA HOST.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM HERE.
THE FEDERAL.
BLOOM. HERE FONG. KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA.
PASS OVER THIS MEASURE FOR THE
MOMENT COME BACK TO IT LATER IN
THE AGENDA.
THAT TAKES US TO CALTRANS.
WE HAVE ONE ISSUE THE INDIRECT
COST RECOVERY PROGRAM.
AND I THAT JUST TO SAY ON THIS
ITEM OF THE AGENDA HAS ADOPTING
A RECOMMENDATION THAT WE ADOPT.
.
AS ARE ALL BUT WE'RE GOING TO.
A HOLE THAT I ITEM OF.
AND HOLD IT OPEN.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GERMAN BLOOM. MONEY
WAS RYAN CHAMBERLAIN ON THE
NEWLY APPOINTED CHIEF.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CALTRANS
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
STEPHEN KHAKI WAS ALSO OUR NEW
CFO FOR CALTRANS REPLACING
ORTEGA. AND STEVEN WOULD
PRESENT.
REPORT ON HONOR INDIRECT COST
RECOVERY PROGRAM.
WELCOME ABOARD SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO THE INDIRECT COST RATE
PROPOSAL OR THE ICRP IS ALL
REFER TO IT MUCH OF NOW ON. IS
THE MEANS BY WHICH A GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES INCLUDING CALTRANS NOT
JUST CALTRANS BY ANY GOVERNMENT
AGENCY THAT DEALS WITH BILLING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ASSIGNS INDIRECT COSTS TO
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS.
INDIRECT COSTS OF THOSE COSTS
WHICH CANNOT EASILY BE ASSIGNED
TO INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO CLEAR CONNECTION TO
THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECT.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER TO BE OVERHEAD IS THE
COMMON PARLANCE IT'S NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE PROJECT.
BUT THAT THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS.
THE PURPOSE OF ASSIGNING THESE
COST TO INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS IS
TO THE IS TWO FOLD ONE. IS TO BE
ABLE TO CAPTURE THE TRUE COST OF
DOING THE WORK.
AND THE SECOND IS TO BE ABLE TO
RECOVER THOSE FULL COSTS ON
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WOMEN WERE
BEING REIMBURSED BY OTHERS WHO
WERE DOING WORK FOR OTHERS.
THE CALTRANS ICRP RATE IS
CALCULATED ON TWO DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS.
AND IT'S CALCULATED BASED ON
FEDERAL REGULATIONS ARE ICRP
RATE IS APPROVED BOTH BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND BY THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
IN OUR CASE.
OTHER GUYS STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES WOULD HAVE THEIR RATE
APPROVED BY THEIR APPROPRIATE
FEDERAL AGENCY.
ARE CALTRANS RATE IS BASED ON
TWO SEPARATE COMPONENTS THE
FIRST IS THE. FUNCTIONAL
OVERHEAD RATE OF THE FUNCTIONAL
ICRP RATE.
THAT IS.
THE LARGER OF THE TWO RATES AND
REFLECTS.
THE INDIRECT COSTS OF CALTRANS
PROJECT DELIVERY PROGRAM.
SUCH IS THE COSTS OF TRAINING
THE EMPLOYEES PROVIDING SPACE
FOR THEM. THE EQUIPMENT THAT
THEY USE THE MANAGEMENT AND THE
SUPERVISION OF THOSE EMPLOYEES.
AND THE SECOND PIECE OF THIS ARE
OVERHEAD COSTS IS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ICRP RATE.
WHICH REFLECT THE COST OF
CALTRANS ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS SUCH AS HUMAN
RESOURCES. ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTING.
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES THE COSTS
OF GOVERNMENT OUTSIDE OF
CALTRANS THE CALTRANS ALSO NEEDS
TO PAY FOR. THOSE ARE STATEWIDE
OF FUNCTIONS SUCH AS STATEWIDE
AUDITING OTHER OPERATIONS OF THE
TREASURER.
AND THE LARGEST PIECE OF THAT
IS CALTRAIN SHARE OF.
RETIRE I'M SORRY IT WITH THE.
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS FOR RETIRED
EMPLOYEES USER CHIU COSTS OF
DOING BUSINESS IN IT'S A COST TO
GO THROUGH THE ICRP WERE ABLE TO
ASSIGN TO INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS.
AND THE RATES ARE APPLIED TO THE
PAYROLL.
COSTS ON A PROJECT SO WHEN WE
CHARGE STAFF TIME TO OTHERS
THOSE RATES ARE APPLIED ONLY IN
THAT CASE IT'S A PERCENTAGE OF
THE STAFF COSTS.
THE STATE'S FULL COST RECOVERY
POLICY REQUIRES US TO PRINT TO
THE CHARGE BOTH OF THESE TWO
RATES TO THE PROJECTS GOING TO
DO THAT.
AND LESS IT'S OTHERWISE
SPECIFIED IN LAW AND YOUR STAFF
A WRITE UP IDENTIFIES THE VERY
FEW INSTANCES WHERE THERE IS AN
EXCEPTION IN LAW WHO WE DON'T
CHARGE EITHER ONE OR BOTH OF
THOSE TWO. TWO COMPONENTS.
.
I CRP REIMBURSEMENTS BY THESE
ENTITIES THAT ARE DEFRAY SOME OF
THE COSTA CALTRANS OF DOING THIS
BUSINESS IN PROPORTION TO THE
WORK THAT WE PERFORM FOR THEM.
THE AMOUNT OF THE
REIMBURSEMENTS IS THAT A AYE
ONCE A RELATIVELY MINOR BUT IN
THE CASE OF SELF HELP COUNTIES
FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR WAS ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT.
ANNA APPLIES TO MUCH OF THE
GREATER.
.
NO CHARGE FOR THE WORK BEING
PERFORMED.
SO THIS ESSENCE BASICALLY
REFLECT THE TRUE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS THE TRUE COSTS OF OF OF
SUPPORTING EMPLOYEES AT
CALTRANS.
AND IT'S AGAIN ONLY FOR THE
DIRECT LABOR BEING PERFORMED ON
THE PROJECT.
WE'VE READ THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO.
FOR THE ILIO TIME. TO REVIEW
THE ICE EUROPEAN DEATH AND WE
SUPPORT THAT RECOMMENDATION THIS
IS COMPLICATED I PROBABLY MADE
IT SOUND VERY EASY IN MY THREE
MINUTE PRESENTATION OF QUITE
SIMPLE YET RIGHT. BUT IT'S IT IS
COMPLICATED AND AND WE WELCOME
THE INSIGHTS HELIO CAN BRING TO
THIS DISC.
I'M GONNA ASK.
EFA ANY OTHER MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO REPEAT.
WITH THAT TO START.
HOW MANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DICE?
LA O. OR HERMAN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE COMMENTS PUBLICIST AT
THE LA SO WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION EITHER.
WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK INTO IT IN
CAN WORK WITH STAFF ON A.
DRAFTING THE REPORTING LANGUAGE
IN THE IN THE DEADLINE.
RIGHT IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DEBATE
WITH THEIR GRADE ASSOCIATES FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT. WE SHOULD
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES.
INTEREST IN REVIEWING THIS ITEM
AS THE STAFF ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THERE'S A. LACK OF CONSISTENCY
IN HOW ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD
IS.
BUDGETED FOR VARIOUS PROJECTS.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
SELF HELP COUNTIES HELP HELP
COUNTIES ARE DOING WORK. ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEMS THAT WORK
WOULD OTHERWISE BE DONE BY
CALTRANS.
IF CALTRANS HAD THE MONEY TO BE
DOING THAT PROJECT WE VIEW THE
SELF HELP COUNTIES AS A STRONG
PARTNER. AND WE DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO BUILD THE SELF
HELP COUNTIES FOR COSTS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECT. IF
THERE'S COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
HEALTH CARE RETIREMENT TRAINING
CROCS.
COST IF ANY OF CALTRANS COST
THOSE ARE APPROPRIATE BUT WHEN
THERE ARE. OUTSIDE COSTS OF
GOVERNMENT WE DON'T THINK THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
PERFORMING THE STATE'S FUNCTION
SHOULD BE CHARGED FOR THOSE
FUNCTIONS AND SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO.
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION WE ARE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND TO
RETURN TO IT.
LATER AGENDA.
I'M SORRY OF COURSE YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST AS
SEVEN YOU HAILS FROM A SELF HELP
COUNTY.
.
I I'M INCLINED TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE COUNTIES PROPOSAL I HEAR
THAT.
.
I GUESS THE COST RECOVERY
CHARGES ARE SOMETIMES AS HIGH AS
THIRTY PERCENT.
SO.
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SELF HELP COUNTIES PROPOSAL I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M ON THE RECORD DATA.
IN THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU I GOT IT AS A BANISTER
MULLIN AYE REPRESENT A SELF HELP
COUNTY I'D I THINK THERE.
REQUEST FOR THAT BEING EXCLUDED
GUY IS IS A GOOD ONE.
DEB AND NOT FOR VERY GOOD
REASONS BUT I I JOIN YOU IN THAT
THAT CONCERN.
YEAH WE'RE HOLD THAT OPEN AND
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
CLICK YOU START A TREND MISTER
MULLIS.
.
ALRIGHT WELL THAT SAID.
I WILL TAKE US TO MEMBER
REQUESTS BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
LET'S SAID TAKE CARE OF OUR VOTE
ONLY COUNTER AND THE.
ONE NIGHT AND I BELIEVE WE ONLY
HAVE ONE ITEM. ON ITEMS TO BE
HEARD THAT WE NEED TO VOTE ON.
.
SO.
IF I COULD DATA.
I HEAR A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY.
ISSUES ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR.
SIX.
EIGHT
TEN THROUGH FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN.
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE.
AT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
BLOOM BY FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
IT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THE
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES THAT WILL CALL
A A IS OUR MOTION ON ITEM FIVE.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
ISSUE SEVEN.
BELOW I FONG.
KALRA. MULLIN PATTERSON.
ISSUE NINE.
BLOOM BY FALL.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
ISSUE FIFTEEN.
BLOW BY FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
ISSUE FIFTEEN.
I'M SORRY IF ISSUE TWENTY.
BOB WE'RE GONNA HANDLE NINETEEN
SEPARATELY SINCE IT WAS PULLED.
JUST TO BE CONSISTENT.
ISSUE TWENTY.
BLOOM I FALL.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
ISSUE TWENTY ONE.
GOT IT PATTERSON A NO ON TWENTY.
BLOOM I FALL.
KALRA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON.
NOW WE TOLD SADA ISSUE NINETEEN
DUH AND HEARD ON THE.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD CALENDAR IS
OUR MOTION ON ITEM NINETEEN.
BLOW BY FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON.
GOOD
WE COVERED ALL THE ITEMS WE HAVE
TO VOTE ON THAT TAKES US TO.
THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
CATEGORY OF ISSUE ONE WHICH IS A
VERY SOON VESTMENT REQUEST THESE
ARE. A REQUEST THAT IF AND.
BROUGHT TO US BY MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY. AND. WE HAVE FOR.
A STIR A AT I CREATED SOME
GROUND RULES HERE TODAY.
A LITTLE BIT UNUSUAL WE.
OF THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF A REQUEST WE'VE ASKED.
MEMBERS TO MAKE PRESENTATIONS
SIR THE LAST NO LONGER THAN
THREE MINUTES
AND THOSE WHO WANT TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THOSE ITEMS.
WERE JUSTICE STATING AN OPINION
ABOUT OF THOSE ITEMS.
A WILL BE ASKED TO JUST STATE
THEIR NAME WHO THEY REPRESENT
AND WHAT THEIR POSITION IS
WITHOUT. A ELABORATION.
SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA WELCOME SIR.
YOU GET THE HONOR OF GOING FIRST
AND UPS IN HONOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
DISTINCTION.
MAYBE EARLY BIRD GETS THE WORM
BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER DAY.
GOOD LUCK.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER INCLUDING
EMERGENCY RELIEF IN THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET THAT WOULD
PROVIDE EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES FAMILIES
AND SCHOOLS.
THE TWENTY THREE AND A HALF
MILLION FUNDING REQUEST INCLUDES
TEN MILLION FOR EMERGENCY ROOM.
EMERGENCY RELIEF OF WELLS AND
SEPTIC SYSTEMS.
TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
EMERGENCY RELIEF INCLUDING WELL
REPLACEMENT SEPTIC SYSTEM
REPLACEMENT PERMANENT
CONNECTIONS TO PUBLIC SYSTEMS.
WELL ABANDONMENT SEPTIC SYSTEM
ABANDONMENT POINT OF USE AND
POINT OF ENTRY SYSTEMS AND DEBT
RELIEF.
THREE AND A HALF MILLION FOR
EMERGENCY RELIEF OF WATER TAKES.
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS
WITH DRY WELLS STILL RELY ON
WATER TANKS THAT ARE FILLED BY
TRUCKS TO SERVE THEIR BASIC
HOUSEHOLD. WATER NEEDS AN
ADDITIONAL HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
EXPERIENCED TOTAL WEALTH
FAILURES IN THE PAST HERE.
THE US TOO LATE TO ACCESS IT
WATER TANK PROGRAM.
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM ENDS ON
JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR AND
THERE IS ANTICIPATED NEED FOR
THIS PROGRAM TO CONTINUE AFTER
JUNE THIRTIETH. WITH TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE TANKS IN THE
GROUND AND AVERAGE INSTALLATION
OF TWELVE TO FIFTEEN NEW WELLS
PER MONTH. THIS WILL STILL MEAN
THAT AROUND TWO HUNDRED TANKS
LEFT TO SERVE AFTER JUNE
THIRTIETH.
AS COMMUNITIES WORK TOWARDS NEW
WELLS AND THE STATE HAS
ALLOCATED FUNDS TO REPLACE DRY
WELLS HOUSEHOLDS NEED IMMEDIATE.
ONGOING ACCESS TO WATER.
CONTINUED FUNDING AS NEEDED TO
INSTALL TANK SYSTEMS FOR HOMES
THAT HAVE HAD WELLS RECENTLY GO
DRY AND CONTINUE TO SUPPLY WATER
TANKS WITH WATER AS AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
STATE WATER BOARD DRINKING WATER
FOR SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
BUILDING ON THE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN STATE BUDGET THIS
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. TO EXPAND THE STATE
WATER BOARD SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR SCHOOLS GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM HELPS TO SUPPLY
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS THAT
CURRENTLY LACK A SOURCE OF CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. WELL LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS ARE STILL BEING
DEBATED FUNDED AND BROUGHT
ONLINE THE STATE WATER BOARDS
DRINKING WATER FOR SCHOOLS
PROGRAM IS A COST EFFECTIVE. LOW
IMPACT WAY TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
SAFE DRINKING WATER ACCESS
TO STUDENTS IN LOW INCOME RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THESE THREE PROGRAMS HAVE VERY
REAL AND MEANINGFUL IMPACTS FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WATER IS A
BASIC NEED AND THESE RESIDENTS
SHOULD HAVE THESE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THAT NEED
IS MET WHILE THE STATE LOOKS FOR
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA IS ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I GOT
CONFLICTING INFORMATION SO WE'RE
DOING THIS NOW AND THAT'S GREAT.
BRIAN AUGUSTA ON SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES AND.
ROLE COMMITTEE ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ALL THE ITEMS IN THIS REQUEST I
WANNA.
PARTICULARLY IF I MAY HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO EXTEND THE TANKS
PROGRAM WHICH WILL END ABRUPTLY
ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
CUTTING OFF
WATER FOR HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES
IN THE VALLEY WHO'VE BEEN LYING
ON THE PROGRAM FOR.
SIX THANK YOU AND TELL YOU MAY
HAVE MISSED MY COMMENT WHERE I.
SAID WILL TAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT.
BUT.
TO SUPPORT OPPOSE AND WITHOUT
ELABORATION UNDERSTANDING OF LAW
AND I KNOW YOU WANT TO BE A
TREND SETTER THERE BUT.
.
AND DE THAT WAS UP MY FAULT I
CREATED THE CONFUSION NOW
BECAUSE I THINK UP PEOPLE WERE
TOLD THAT THAT WE WOULD DO ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE END
BUTTOCK BELLAVIA TRANSIT OR JUST
TO HAVE A CHANGE THE RULE ON
THAT I THINK IT'LL FLOW LITTLE
BIT EASIER IF WE JUST.
BY A HERO WHO SUPPORTING WHAT
TO AS THE.
ITEMS HURTS UP THANK YOU FOR
THAT SIR AND TO A WILL TAKE IT
UNDER CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
ARE.
NEXT A PRESENTER IS MISTER DAVID
CHIU.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PROJECT
BEING THE SECOND IN THE LINE OF
TRENDSETTERS HERE.
SO WELL THIS FUNDING REQUEST IS
RELATED TO THE SEA WALL LOT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND IN ADDITION
TO.
HOUSING NEEDS THIS IS.
MY TOP FUNDING PRIORITY FOR SAN
FRANCISCO AT THIS TIME FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
VISIT OURCITY.
AND I HOPE THAT IS NONE OF YOU
BUT HAPPY TO GIVE YOU ARE TOUR
IF THIS IS SOMETHING YOU ARE
INTERESTED IN OUR SAN FRANCISCO
SEA WALL TEAM MARKET ERA SEA
WALL HELPS TO PROTECT. THE SAN
FRANCISCO WATERFRONT IT WAS
BUILT OVER A CENTURY AGO. AND
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY IT IS
RAPIDLY DETERIORATING AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE TO
EARTHQUAKE AND SEA LEVEL RISE.
IT'S
A VERY CRITICAL ASSET WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING REGIONAL AND
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE IT PROTECTS
OVER A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND ASSETS
IT'S WHERE MILLIONS LIVE WORK
AND PLAY. INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR
MILLION VISITORS TO OUR STATE
AND OUR CITY EVERY YEAR. THE
CITY WILL ALSO PROTECTS CRITICAL
UTILITY JUST DUMP NETWORKS AS
WELL AS REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE BAY. OF
I'VE A BILL THAT BUILDS ON A LAW
THAT WAS PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE SOME THIRTEEN YEARS
AGO THAT ALLOW FOR THE FORMATION
OF AN INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT. ALONG RC WALL TO FUND
IMPROVEMENTS TO AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HISTORIC
RESOURCES OF THE BILL WOULD
REVISE OUR IT LAW TO INCLUDE THE
SHORELINE PROTECTION THAT WE
NEED TO REBUILD OUR SEE WHAT.
AT THIS TIME IT'S ESTIMATED TO
REBUILD OUR SEA WALL IT'LL COST
US BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AT THE LATEST PRICE TAG IS
ABOUT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT FROM LOCAL SOURCES
FEDERAL SOURCES PRIVATE SOURCES
AND WE HOPE FROM THE STATE THE
ACID I HAVE IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS FOR A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR. INVESTMENT.
THAT COMPARES TO FOR EXAMPLE A
LOCAL BALLOT MEASURE THAT'S
GOING TO SAN FRANCISCO VOTERS
FOR MANY TIMES AT THIS COMING
FALL. A AND WITH THAT I VERY
MUCH HOPE THAT YOU COULD HELP IN
THIS INVESTMENT.
THAT WILL NOT REALLY PROTECT
NOT JUST A CITY ASSET BUT STATE
AND REGIONAL ASSN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIGN IS CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS
PAUL YOUR SHUTTER ENTRY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
SAN CISCO THERE IS A COMPELLING
STATE INTEREST STATED BY MR
CHIU.
FINGERS A FUNDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU WE HAVE FOR.
SIR BIGELOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WELCOME SIR.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I SEE
YOU'RE CHUCKLING HOPEFULLY
THAT'S GOOD NOT ABOUT ABOUT YOU.
I I THREE NINE WE CAN IF YOU
LIKE.
SO FAR NOT ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT'S
A.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A FUN
REFLECTION YOU KNOW HAVING
SERVED ON THE COMMITTEE UP
AWHILE BACK SO. I'M MISSING THE
OFFICE OF.
ANYWAY LET ME START OFF BY
SAYING ARE GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER A TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR. A REQUEST
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS I
REDUCTION FUND FOR WATER SUPPLY
AND WASTE WATERS SYSTEM
PROJECTS.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
DELIVERING WATER WAS INSTALLED
AFTER THE SECOND WORLD WAR WHICH
WAS MORE THAN SEVEN DECADES AGO.
AS YOU KNOW WATER IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCES AND WITHOUT FUNDING TO
REPLACE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
BIPLANES. AND OTHER IMPORTANT
FACILITIES TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
WATER CAN BE LOST.
THIS IS DEAR WATER THAT WE
SOMETIMES JUST CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH PROVIDING ENOUGH FOR
EVERYONE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STATEWIDE
ISSUE BUT ONE THAT PARTICULARLY
IMPACTS RURAL AREAS AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. REPLACING
OLD WATER INFRASTRUCTURE USING
DOLLARS FROM THE G. G. R. F..
FUND WILL SHOW THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO INVESTING IN WATER
USE AND SUPPLY.
IN ADDITION TO KEEPING IN LINE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S CARBON
REDUCTION GOALS.
THAT'S MY FIRST REQUEST OUT TO
THE COMMITTEE MY SECOND REQUEST
SECONDLY I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDS. FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA WOULD INNOVATION
SMALL GRANT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION.
I'D LIKE TO REQUEST A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR ON GOING FUND FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP
IMPROVE OUR HEALTHY FORESTS.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A SEVERE TREE
MORTALITY CRISIS AND MUST
ADDRESS SOLUTIONS FOR THE MORE
THAN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION DEAD OR DYING TREES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND I DO MEAN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WELL WE'VE SEEN THE
DEAD AND DYING TREES FROM KERN
COUNTY ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH
THE BEGINNINGS OF CALAVERAS
COUNTY. WE'RE NOW SEEING IT
EXTENDING ALL THE WAY UP INTO EL
DORADO COUNTY AND FARTHER SO THE
NUMBERS ARE GOING TO GROW
RAPIDLY EXPONENTIALLY.
USING A GT R. F. FUNDS TO
ESTABLISH THE SMALL GRANTS
PROGRAM WOULD INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIZATIONS AND BUSINESSES TO
DEVELOP WOOD PRODUCTS WITH THE
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT OF REMOVING
DANGEROUS TREES.
AND THE EXCESS BIOMASS THAT AS
WE KNOW ARE CREATING TREMENDOUS
FIRES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
AND I ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
AS YOU CONSIDER THESE ITEMS ARE
FOR THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU OF OF FOR PRESENTING
ON THEM.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BOB READ WITH REAL
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF ELDORADO IRRIGATION DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEMBERS
REQUEST. THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND APPROPRIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM A MS LIMO.
ANOTHER PUBLIC OF MY SORRY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE WENDY WRITER BUSH WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF
THAT REQUEST A VIA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS LIMON.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS AND HERE
A REQUEST TO ADD THREE MILLION
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND AND FUNDS
FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES WHICH PROTECTS
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREAS.
SIA'S LANDS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE THE SIX COUNTIES ARE
CURRENT LOS ANGELES MARINE
ORANGE SANTA BARBARA BEEN
TRAPPED I REPRESENT PARTS OF TO
THESE CONTRACT COUNTIES. SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA AS YOU MAY
ALREADY KNOW EACH OF THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES EXPERIENCE
WILDFIRES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WITHIN TRANSCEND BARBARA
COUNTIES. FIGHTING THE LARGEST
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY HENCE
MY REASON FOR BEING HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THESE FIRE
AGENCIES.
THE SIX COUNTIES WERE PREVIOUSLY
IN AGREEMENT WITH CAL FIRE TO
RECEIVE CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING
BASED ON A PRE AGREED FORMULA
WHICH ENTITLED THE SIX COUNTIES
TO AN AMOUNT EQUIVALENT TO.
NINETEEN PERCENT OF CAL FIRE
SIX COUNTIES RECEIVED THIS
NINETY PERCENT FUNDING FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWELVE. ACCORDING TO
VENTURA COUNTY FIRE CHIEF MARK
LORENZEN IN TWENTY TWELVE CAL
FIRE PREFER INFORMS THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES THAT IT COULD NO LONGER
PROVIDE CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING
BECAUSE THIS FUNDING WAS NOW
BEING FUNDED FROM LEASE REVENUE
BONDS. AND REQUIRED THE STATE
PROPERTIES TO BE USED AS
COLLATERAL WHICH PREEMPTED
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE COUNTIES
EVER SINCE TWENTY TWELVE THE SIX
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN PURSUING
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING IN THE
REGULAR BUDGETPROCESS USING THE
AGREED UPON NINETEEN PERCENT
FORMULA. IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
APPROPRIATION FOR CONTRACT
COUNTIES AND IT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL BUDGET SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. LAST YEAR'S THE
COUNTIES WAITED WAITED OUT THE
PROCESS AND DID NOT PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE OF UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE
FEDERAL BUDGET IMPACT ON THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET. THE COUNTIES
NOW RETURN WITH THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY REQUEST FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
CONTRACT COUNTIES WOULD PREFER
TO HAVE A PERMANENT FIX AND IT
CONTINUES TO PREPARATION FOR
THESE AGREED UPON CAPITAL OUTLAY
MANY'S.
AND CALIFORNIA'S SUPPOSED THIS
REQUEST FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
FUNDING TO OUR COUNTIES THIS
BUDGET REQUEST HAS THE SUPPORT
OF MORE THAN TWENTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS EACH OF WHOM REPRESENTS
ONE OR MORE OF THE SIX CONTRACT
COUNTIES IN A TIME WHEN WE ARE
SEEING. MORE DISASTERS THIS
FUNDING WILL BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT FOR THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH THIS IN MIND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BATTERY
PLASTIC YOU VERY MUCH PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE.
ERIC CARLSON REPRESENT THE
ASSOCIATION CONTRACT COUNTIES
AGAIN KERN LOS ANGELES MARIN
ORANGE SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA.
FIRE DEPARTMENT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY WE'VE BEEN THAT
TRACKING MEMBERS ASYOU'VE BEEN
THEY'RE WALKING IN AND TO THINK
WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY WRITTEN DOWN
BUT IF WE MISS ONE OF YOU JUST
ELEVEN SNOW.
WE HAVE FLAT NEXT IN THE QUEUE
UP AND MISS WALDRON.
AND THEN THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MORNING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR THE CITY OF ESCONDIDO
AS WASHINGTON PARK. WHICH WAS
ACQUIRED BY THE CITY IN NINETEEN
THIRTEEN. IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
THE PULL WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
IMPROVEMENTS. BY THE LATE
SIXTIES THE MOST CURRENT
IMPROVEMENTS WERE INSTALLED THE
BASEBALL FIELD BASKETBALL COURTS
POOL COMMUNITY BUILDING. TENNIS
COURTS WERE ADDED IN THE
SEVENTIES.
RENOVATIONS TO THE EXISTING
FACILITIES HAVE OCCURRED IN A
PIECEMEAL FASHION OVER THE YEARS
AS FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE. SO
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A COMPLETE
RENOVATION.
FOR EXAMPLE WE SURFACING OF THE
BASKETBALL INTENDED BECAUSE
COURTS COULDN'T HAVE NOT
OCCURRED IN OVER TEN YEARS WITH
FENCING AROUND THE BASEBALL
FIELD. OVER THIRTY YEARS OLD.
WASHINGTON PARK IS EXTENSIVELY
USED BY THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND
SERVES AS A VITAL RESOURCE TO
THE COMMUTE COMMUNITY BUT A
SEVERELY ON THE FUNDING. IN
TERMS OF MAINTENANCE AND
RENOVATION.
LOCATED IN THE OLD URBAN CORE OF
THE CITY OF ESCONDIDO WASHINGTON
PARK IS A CENTRAL POINT. IN A
MINORITY LOW INCOME UNDERSERVED
AREA OF THE CITY SURROUNDED BY
DENSE MULTI FAMILY AND RENTAL
HOUSING. SERVING AN ESTIMATED
POPULATION OF OVER FORTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
CENSUS TRACTS SURROUNDING THE
PARK AMONGST THE LOWEST IN THE
NATION WITH AVERAGE LOW INCOME
INCOMES.
FOR FAMILIES OF FOR A THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND UNLESS.
WITH A NINETY ONE PERCENT
MINORITY POPULATION. THIS
DEMOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY NEEDS A NICE UPGRADED
PARK. FOR RECREATION AND FAMILY
OUTINGS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST.
YOU'RE WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS REQUEST
GOOD MORNING CHRISTY FOR A WITH
ARNOLD AND ASSOCIATES HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ESCONDIDO
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT. THE
WASHINGTON PARK PROJECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARM I HAVE A
THE SECOND REQUEST PLEASE A VERY
QUICKLY THE FALLBROOK PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT OWNS THE LAST
UNPROTECTED LENGTH OF THE SANTA
MARGARITA RIVER. WHICH REMAINS
THE SOLE ACCESS POINT TO THE
RIVER FOR THE GREATER PUBLIC.
THE SANTA MARGARITA RIVER
PARKWAY IS AN ECOLOGICAL A
RECREATIONAL TREASURE FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE
AND ORANGE COUNTY'S. AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING AN
EIGHTEEN MILE TRAIL TRAVERSED BY
HIKERS BIKERS EQUESTRIANS YOUNG
AND OLD OF ALL BACKGROUNDS.
THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
HAS A PLAN TO PURCHASE THE FALL
BOOK PUBLIC UTILITY OF IT
DISTRICT PROPERTY SO LONG AS THE
REQUESTED FUNDING IS PROVIDED
ALONG WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP
SIXTY EIGHT ON THE JUNE FIFTH
THE BALLOT.
THIS PURCHASE WOULD ENSURE THE
PROPERTY REMAINS OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC.
AND THIS THIS ASK ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT IF THE BOND IS PASSED
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR THE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT.
WOULD BE A FROM THAT BOND.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS ISSUE AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS CONSIDERATION.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
A COMMENT.
YES CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAN YOUR
CALL INS CONSERVANCY IN WE WOULD
BE TAKING A FEW TITLE AND
STEWARDSHIP OF THIS PROPERTY
IT'S MAGNIFICENT. RIVER PROPERTY
AND WOULD BE OPEN AND FREE TO
THE PUBLIC IN PERPETUITY SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY.
COULD BREAK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT I WANT TO JUST I'M
NOT ASKING FOR TECHNICAL FIX ON
A TRANSPORTATION.
ITEM THE ME EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
THE GVW VEHICLES HAS BEEN WHAT
IT IS AND EIGHT THE SAFETY OF
THESE VEHICLES HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE TIME SO.
YOU HAD GAS ENGINES WITHOUT
BINGEING BREAKS WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY LIGHT BREAKS AND SO
BASICALLY THE SAFETY OF THE
VEHICLES AS INCREASE BUT ALSO AT
THE GVW THOSE VEHICLES. HAS
INCREASED AS WELL.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THERE WAS A. OF
THAT LEGISLATION THE CAPE
THROUGH THAT CAPTURED THESE
VEHICLES BECAUSE OF WEIGHT AND
SO I'M SIMPLY TRYING TO.
MAKE IT MAKES SOME SENSE AND I'M
TRYING TO. A NARROWLY CRAFTED
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO REVENUE
LOST BUT IT WILL ALLOW SO THAT
WE GIVE EXAMPLE IF YOU OWN A
LANDSCAPING. BUSINESS AND YOU
HAVE A BOX ON THE BACK YOUR
TRUCK YOUR CAPTURED IN THIS BI
ANNUAL INSPECTION.
THIS BILL FOR THIS THIS MEASURE
WOULD ALLOW YOU TO AB.
NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
INSPECTION AND IT DO YOU NEED TO
KNOW ALSO THAT DEBT PUBLIC
AGENCIES DON'T.
HAVE TO DO THIS SO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T DO IT IF THEY
HAVE THAT X. SAME STYLE OF
TALL READ YOU WHAT IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO DO BUT I WANTED IT TO
US SET THAT UP SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT I'M TRYING TO
ALLOW SMALL LANDSCAPING FOLKS
NOT HAVE TO GET CAPTURED IN
THIS.
IN THIS NEW REGULATION THE
EXEMPTION HAS A GROSS VEHICLE
WEIGHT RATING OF TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND AND LIMITS PICK UP OR
TOW VEHICLES FROM EXCEEDING A
GROSS VEHICLE WEIGHT OF SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ONE POUNDS.
THE LANGUAGE ALSO ENSURES
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW BY
INCLUDING ONLY THOSE VEHICLES
THAT OPERATE IN INTERSTATE.
INTERSTATE COMMERCE VEHICLES
THAT OPERATE IN ENTRUST STATE
CONGRESS.
ARE SUBJECT TO THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY THE
FEDERAL MOTOR CARRIER SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION'S ARE EXCLUDED.
THE SAFETY OF VEHICLES INCLUDE
UNDER THE EXEMPTION WILL NOT BE
LEFT UNCHECKED BASED ON THEIR
WEIGHT AND CONFIGURATION.
THESE VEHICLES AND VEHICLE
COMBINATIONS ARE LIKELY TO STILL
REQUIRE A MOTOR CARRIER PERMIT
ISSUED BY DMV.
TRAVEL THROUGH ROADWAYS
INSPECTION STATIONS MANNED BY
CHP AT HERE TO FEDERAL.
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
REGULATIONS FOR THOSE TRAVELING.
INTERSTATE PAY WAIT PEAS AT HERE
TO THE HOURS OF SERVICE AND LOG
BOOK REQUIREMENTS JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
AN EXEMPTION IS ENFORCEABLE
RELATIVELY TO GROSS VEHICLE
WEIGHT MANUFACTURES POST THE
WEIGHT OF THE PICK UPS AND
TRAILERS ON THE DOOR JAM OR THE
NECK OF THE TRAILER. SIMPLY
SIMPLE ARITHMETIC CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PICK UP EXCEED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND POUNDS OR A
COMBINATION TWENTY SIX. NOW
THAT'S A LOT SAID BUT BASICALLY
WHAT. IF YOU'RE GONNA BE OVER
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND VALUE WILL
BE REGULATE IF YOU'RE IN A
COMBINATION IF YOU'RE UNDER THAT
YOU WILL NOT.
AND IT WILL SIMPLY BRING FOLKS
THAT ARE AT LANDSCAPING AND
SMALL OPERATIONS IT AT. A INTO
COMPLIANCE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
ON THIS REQUEST.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
WE WILL HEAR FROM MADNESS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. OF AND I'LL
JUST A RUN THROUGH THE LIST NOW
SEE ALL KNOW WHERE YOU ARE IN
THE QUEUE.
MISTER FRAZIER AGUIAR-CURRY
WOULD DALY CABALLERO EGGMAN AND
CHEN HAVE I MISSED ANYBODY.
GREAT.
WELL HERE I TRIED REQUEST MISTER
CHAIRMAN SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE TO REQUEST THIS MORNING THE
FIRST I'D LIKE TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF MY REQUESTS FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP COMBAT
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE. IN
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR IMPACT OF
THE INVASIVE SHOT HOLE BORE
BEETLE ON CALIFORNIA'S TREES.
THAT'S FAR THERE'S NOT BEEN A
COORDINATED STATEWIDE EFFORT TO
COMBAT THE SPREAD OF THESE
BEETLES WHICH IF LEFT UNCHECKED
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOSS OF
EVEN MORE TREES INCREASING FIRE
HAZARDS PUBLIC SAFETY RISKS. AN
INNOCENT DIEGO COUNTY AT THE LAS
OF AVOCADO TREES. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THAT I ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER APPROPRIATING TURNER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
COORDINATION BETWEEN INVASIVE
SPECIES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA THE
COUPLE INVASIVE SPECIES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. STATE LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
TO DEVELOP A PLAN FOR THE
SUPPRESSION A CURE OF DISEASE.
ASSOCIATED WITH A SHOT HOLE WAR.
FOUR POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION
FOR THE USE UPON COMPLETION OF
THE PLAN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD ANNOUNCED HIS SUPPORT STATE
LOCAL EFFORTS TO CURE AND
SUPPRESS THE DISEASES INCLUDING
RESEARCH AND GRANTS TO LOCAL
AGENCIES.
SECOND I'M HERE IS VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF OUR ASK FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DRINKING WATER FOR SCHOOLS
PROGRAM. WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
SCHOOLS. ARE ABLE TO FIX ISSUES
OF CONTAMINATION THERE FOUND AND
CONTINUE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
CHILDREN ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE
PROGRAM ONLY FUND PROJECTS AT
FIVE HUNDRED SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE SO THAT BE WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE IF I IF AS WE KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW SCHOOLS
BEGIN TO IDENTIFY CONTAMINANTS
IN THE WATER LAST YEAR WE PASSED
A BILL REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO TEST
OUR WATER FOR LEAD. AND I'M AS
THEY HAVE FOUND TOO MANY
POSITIVE TEST FOR LEAD OTHER
DOES HAVE TO BE REPLACEMENT OF
OF THAT NUMBER THINGS IN SCHOOLS
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS.
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAKE ANY CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS NEEDED TO REMOVE HARMFUL
CONTAMINANTS FROM WATER ONCE OUR
COUNT. THAT'S ALL I GOT MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND FOR CLARIFICATION
SAKE THAT'S THE SHOT HOLE BORER
NOT THE SHOT FULL BORE FOR FETAL
IT'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING ELSE BUT
I COULDN'T PRONOUNCE POLY.
SAVILE BLASTS IN KARAJ AYE YEAH
I HAVE AYE AYE.
I I THINK MY STAFF FOR THE VERY
AMBITIOUS TALKING POINTS BUT
IT'S A BEETLE.
THAT'S IT THE BEETLE IT'S VERY
INVASIVE BEETLE IT'S A SERIOUS
PROBLEM I DON'T MEAN TO MAKE
LIGHT OF IT. BUT WE DO TEND TO
BE A LITTLE BIT BORING
SOMETIMES.
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT
AND EITHER OF THESE ITEMS PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FRIENDSTER MAKER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST COUNCIL
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE FIRST ITEM
REGARDING THE SHOT HOPE OR
WORDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEN ARCHIE'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL IN BOTH
THE CHICA LAND TRUST AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIRST ASKING
COMBATING CHUCKLE BORDERS THINK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING TASHA NEWMAN AYE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BIG SUR
LAND TRUST AND THE CINEMA AG AN
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT. IN SUPPORT
OF THOSE SHOT HOLE BORDER.
REQUEST.
BOB BRYAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF A
NUMBER OF GROUPS IN SUPPORT OF
THE SECOND REQUEST ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN SCHOOLS
INCLUDING. RURAL COMMUNITIES
SYSTEMS CORPORATION SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES.
CRLA FOUNDATION LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL. THREE WATER CENTER.
CALIFORNIA GOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
AND POLICY LINK.
MORNINGSTAR MILLS A CALIFORNIA
RELIEF HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FIRST ITEM ON SHUTTLE BORE.
ONE OF THEM WE DON'T KNOW
WITHOUT BY CALIFORNIA HEARING
SUPPORT FIRST ITEM. TO BE
INVASIVE BEETLE.
I THINK.
GOOD MORNING LUCAS FACTS ABOUT
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF A SHOT HOLE BORE A
QUEST AS WELL.
THE INVASIVE BEETLE HAPPEN IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE I THINK I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY.
DOCTOR MONDO VALERIO PRIVATE
CITIZENS SUPPORT OF THE SECOND
ITEM.
MAY I WITH THE BEATLE INVASION
SORRY.
GEN NINE WITH YOUR CHILDREN'S
TREES IN GO LEADER IN SUPPORT OF
THE.
AND BASS PUNCH MODEL POOR ITEM.
ROSE UP PERSON FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL SOCIETY OF ARBOR
CULTURE.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE SHUTTLE
BART.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THOSE COMMENTS
AND THAT WILL MOVE ON TO MISS
FRAZIER.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR
CONSIDERATION TO ALLOCATE NINETY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS. FROM
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT IN VA
FOR AT LEAST FOUR HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS.
THIS WILL RESTRICT OR THE
DEPARTMENT TO IS TRADITIONAL
STAFFING WELL LEVEL AND HELP
ADDRESS THE RISING TOLL OF
TRAFFIC DEATHS
ON THE STATE HIGHWAYS.
SIMPLE FACT STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST FOR EXAMPLE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TEN.
THE STATE'S POPULATION HAS
INCREASED EIGHT POINT FOUR
PERCENT.
REGISTERED VEHICLES HAVE
INCREASED ELEVEN POINT SIX
PERCENT.
LICENSED DRIVERS HAVE INCREASED
ELEVEN POINT THREE PERCENT.
MEANWHILE CRASHES HAVE INCREASED
TWENTY NINE PERCENT.
THE MILEAGE DEATH RATE HAS
INCREASED TO TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT.
CHP PERSONNEL HAS DECREASED FIVE
FROM SEVEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT.
TWO SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE.
IN OTHER WORDS CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION NUMBER OF REGISTERED
VEHICLES UNLICENSED DRIVER
CONTINUE TO INCREASE WHILE THE
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFERS HAVE.
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS HAVE
BECOME MORE SCARCE.
THE RESULTS OF THESE DIVERGENT
TRENDS ARE CLEAR. MORE ACCIDENTS
AND INCREASED RETAIL FATALITY
RATE.
RESOLVING THIS TRAGIC TREND IS
VERY SIMPLE.
THE PRESENCE OF OUR OFFICERS ON
OUR HIGHWAYS DETERS UNSAFE
DRIVING BEHAVIORS.
FOR TOO LONG IS BEEN TOO EASY
FOR RECKLESS DRIVERS TO SPEED.
AND DRIVE WHILE IMPAIRED OR
DISTRACTED OR MAKE OTHER UNSAFE
CHOICES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NINETY
SIX THOUSAND TICKETS WERE GIVEN
OUT FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING ALONE
LAST YEAR.
WHERE THESE OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
DISTRACTED THEMSELVES WERE
TRYING TO ENFORCE? THAT TEN
DOLLAR.
PENALTY.
STUDIES SHOW THAT IN THE ABSENCE
OF ENFORCEMENT DRIVERS ARE LIKE
LESS LIKELY TO AND FOLLOW THE
LAW OF THE LAND AND MAINTAIN
SAFE TRAVELING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL OF US.
I BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
BEGIN TO BRING OUR HIGHWAY
PATROL BACK INTO ALIGNMENT WITH
OUR GROWTH.
A GROWING POPULATION.
FOR REFERENCE OF THE NUMBER OF
HIGHWAY PATROL PERSONAL
INCREASED THE EIGHT POINT FOUR
PERCENT CENSUS TWO THOUSAND
LEVEL.
TO KEEP UP WITH THE STATE'S
POPULATION GROWTH. WE WE SHOULD
HAVE EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
OFFICERS PATROLLING OUR STATE.
THAT WOULD BEING AN INCREASE OF
ROUGHLY ONE THOUSAND OFFICERS
MORE THAN THE STATE CURRENTLY
EMPLOYEES.
AGAIN I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
MAKE THIS SAFETY EFFORT A
PRIORITY IN OUR STATE BUDGET.
I KNOW THEY EARN READ WAS FORCED
TO JOIN ME TO THE SET THE SET
THIS MORNING BROUGHT HIGH.
I GOT NUMBER TWO YOU BAKER IS
HERE WITH THEIR READS OFFICE TO.
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DEBATE
WITH THEIR GREATNESS AS HIS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN IN SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND. WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM THE CROWD AND I
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE ASK I
I'M I'M.
BUT TO SUPPORT IT AND WANT TO
MAKE THAT NOTED I THINK IT'S A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT ASK FOR
THE REASONS OF THE. OTHER
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT
TO US THANK YOU I JUST KNOW THAT
IF I IF I MISTER CHAIR.
WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS KILLED IN
AND THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND THERE
WAS AN OFF DUTY HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS THAT KEPT MY SECOND ON
ALIVE.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SAFETY TO OUR RESIDENTS
WITHOUT IT RESPECT ESCRIBIR.
THANK YOU.
AND MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
YOU'RE UP NEXT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
I KNOW YOU ARE ALL WELL WELL
AWARE OF THE WILDFIRES IN MY
DISTRICT AND MISTER WOODS MISLI
MOANS THIS PAST YEAR SO I WILL
NOT TAKE YOUR TIME RECAPPING THE
DEVASTATION AND LOSS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND PEOPLE AND
SEVERAL OTHERS AREAS OF THE
STATE.
I'M APPEARING BEFORE YOU TO ASK
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO MODERNIZE
AND STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
INCLUDING LOCAL AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENTS THROUGH OH YES
FOR PRE POSITIONING.
OUR SYSTEM IS A NATIONAL MODEL
MODEL BUT IS DESIGNED AS
REACTIVE
THIS ARGUMENTATION WILL ADDRESS.
THESE ISSUES IMPROVE TECHNOLOGY
AND HELP TO TURN OUR MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM INTO A PROACTIVE SYSTEM.
THE FUNDS WOULD BE SPENT AS
FOLLOWS.
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COSTS FOR PRE
POSITIONING RESOURCES IN HIGH
RISK AREAS DURING PERIODS OF RED
FLAG FIRE CONDITIONS.
THIS WILL ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
STRIKE TEAMS TO PREVENT FIRES
FROM BECOMING CATASTROPHIC.
MOBILIZING THE STRIKE TEAMS
BECAUSE
BROUGH MOBILIZING THE STRIKE
TEAMS COST GOVERNMENT'S APPROACH
THE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY.
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO PAY
FOR IMPROVE COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGIES TO ALLOW MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE RESOURCE
DEPLOYMENT.
THIS FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE FOR
THEM RETROFIT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EQUIPMENT TO MIR
SAFETY TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
ALREADY BEING DEPLOYED IN STATE
OWNED EQUIPMENT.
IS THE NEW THIS IS A NEW STATE
OF THE ART SYSTEM FOR REQUESTING
AND MANAGING RESOURCES FOR LARGE
SCALE EMERGENCIES. ADDITIONAL OH
YES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERSONNEL TO STAFF REGIONAL
DISPATCH CENTERS AND IMPROVE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR ALERTING
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES OF
APPROACHING THREATS.
LEADER SO CALIFORNIA FIRE
SERVICE TELL US THAT THE
STRATEGIES AND RESOURCES WE ARE
ASKING FOR TODAY CAN HELP
PREVENT THESE FIRES FROM
BECOMING MEGA FIRES. AND MAY
HAVE MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR FIREFIGHTERS
PLEASE FOR YEARS SUPPORT OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND FUND THE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE FIRE CHIEF
SOME FIREFIGHTERS ARE
REQUESTING.
TO GIVE THEM THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE TO KEEP ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY SAFE FROM THESE
INCREASINGLY DEVASTATING CLIMATE
DRIVEN EVENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
WE HAVE MUSLIM ON AND.
MISTER WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SAY A FEW WORDS.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF. THESE FIRES
THAT BURN THROUGH OUR DISTRICTS
IN OCTOBER OF THAT MISTAKE YOUR
CREAM MYSELF WERE THE MOST.
EXPENSIVE IN AMERICAN HISTORY
CLAIMING OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
HOMES AND FORTY THREE LIVES THEY
CHANGED THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR
EVER. IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE HAS
THE HEROIC EFFORTS OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS THE F. DESPITE THE
TOLL MIGHT HAVE BEEN MUCH MUCH
HIGHER.
THIS HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FIRE PROTECTION FUNDING.
IN HOPE WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS
IN HOPES THAT WHEN THE NEXT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE HITS OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS WILL HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED THAT SO THAT
WHAT WE'RE BETTER PREPARED
BETTER PROTECTED. AND THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. A SINCE COMING TO
THIS LEGISLATURE I'VE BEEN A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR MANAGEMENT
INVESTMENT IN OUR WILD LANDS IN
THIS YEAR HAVE YET ANOTHER BILL
AIMED AT INVESTING MORE
RESOURCES IN CHANGING HOW WE
MANAGE OUR WILD LANDS. BUT
THAT'S THE LONG GAME WE DUG
OURSELVES TO BIG HOLD THE FOCUS
ON RESOURCE MANAGEMENT FIRE
PREVENTION ALONE. PAST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES CLIMATE
CHANGE DROUGHT AN INFESTATION
OUR BORDERS AND BEATLES. THOMAS
WHO HAVE CREATED A LANDSCAPE
THAT ALL BUT GUARANTEES MORE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
TWELVE OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN THE
LAST SIXTEEN YEARS. THESE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES DEMAND
THAT WE INVEST IN ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE RESPONSE
RESOURCES AS WELL OF INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES TO PREVENT PREAMP AND
MITIGATE DISASTERS WHENEVER
POSSIBLE. LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE SERVICE TELL
US THAT THE STRATEGIES AND
RESOURCES WE'RE ASKING FOR TODAY
CAN HELP PREVENT THESE FIRES
BECOME FROM BECOMING THE MEGA
FIRES AT MISS AGUILAR CURRY
SPOKE ABOUT. AND IT MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN OUR DISTRICT LAST
OCTOBER EIGHTH.
WITH DID THE REQUEST WILL
REIMBURSE LOCAL FIRE AGENCIES
FOR PRE POSITION THROUGH OUR
EXISTING MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AS
WELL AS MODERNIZE THE DIGITAL
THAT THAT THIS PAST TECHNOLOGY.
WE SUPPORT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
FUND THE STRATEGIES FOR OUR FIRE
CHIEFS AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE
ASKING FOR THIS FOR HELP KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
BOB FROM THESE WORSENING CLIMATE
DRIVEN EVENTS THANK MISTER
CHAIR.
I'M PROUD TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
IN ASKING FOR THE EXPANSION AND
MODERNIZATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FIRES
EXPOSE CLEAR WEAKNESSES IN A
SYSTEM THAT WAS NOT BUILT TO
RESPOND TO THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
THESE YEAR ROUND DISASTERS.
COUPLED WITH PREVENTION THIS
NEIGHBOR HELPING NEIGHBOR
APPROACH FOR FIREFIGHTING MUST
BECOME A PRIORITY AS CALIFORNIA
IS FACING A YEAR ROUND FIRE
SEASON THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I ALSO WOULD HAVE
MISTER NOT KEPT NICKEL HERE IF
YOU HAVE ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
I ASSUME YOU WANT TO ADD ON A
PUBLIC COMMENT ALSO AND THEN.
THE FOLKS BEHIND YOU CAN NOT
CONTINUE.
GREAT THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
I WISH IT WASN'T HALF TO WISH
IT WASN'T HERE TO HAVE TO ASK
FOR THIS AYE THAT WE HAD
RESOLVED THIS PROBLEM THAT. THE
REASON THAT YOU SEE ARE A LOT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES HERE
IS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE MUTUAL AID FOR
THESE LARGE INCIDENTS
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ASKING. A
THROUGH A VERY BROAD BASED
COALITION.
COMPRISED OF CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS I
REPRESENT THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
FIRE CHIEFS DEPARTMENT AS THE
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF PALO
ALTO. ARE AS WELL AS THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IT'S A
BROAD BASED LABOR AND MANAGEMENT
COALITION FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE HISTORY THE FIRE SERVICE
THAT HAS COME TOGETHER TO MAKE
THIS ASKED WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RICHARD GERE'S FIRE CHIEF THAT
IRAQ FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TRY BEAR DEPUTY
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CONSUMERS
FIRE DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF A.
COUSIN IS FIRE AND ALSO CAL
CHIEFS OPERATIONS SECTION
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SCOTT WESTERN OPA
INTERNET THE FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY CENTER IS A FAR ARE IN
SPORTING'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
OBSERVERS I MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA FORWARD
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ONGOING WORK IN SUPPORT
FOR SERVICE.
DID YOU TURN MEMBERS RYAN PARINI
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BUDGET ASK THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING STOP A ZOMBIE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POL EURA
BEHALF OF THE BOARD SU RISE IN
CINEMA.
MENDOCINO NAPA COUNTIES VERY
GRATEFUL OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THINK.
AFFECT WORKERS HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION OF SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND STRUCK
SUPPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU THANK THE
PRESENTATION.
MISTER PATTERSON.
THIS IS REAL AND IT DIDN'T GET
OUT I I FELT LIKE I SHOULD MAYBE
JUST GO TO THE PUBLIC MY THING
TO SAY WHEN HE GOT ME TO.
THANK YOU FOR THIS TO A MEMBER
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
A PRE POSITIONING FOR.
EFFORTS PRE POSITIONING IS
CRUCIAL AND KEY WE HAD THE
RIMFIRE IT SMOKED FOR AWHILE HAD
WE BEEN ABLE TO DO A QUICK.
OUT OF IT REPOSITIONING THAT
FIRE MAY HAVE BEEN KNOCKED DOWN
THERE. MUCH EARLIER AND I HOPE
THAT THE THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHER MEMBERS UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR THE
STRATEGIC IN THE TACTICAL
APPROACH.
A THAT THAT IT IS NECESSARY BUT
ALSO FOR NOW THE SAFETY OF. THE
OTHER FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL PRE
POSITIONING IS SO KIANA BRIT
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOU TO BRING
THIS FORWARD AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING IT FORMALLY WHEN
IT COMES UP AND I CAN.
FONG.
I DISAGREE WITH THAT I AGREE
WITH MR PASSION AND. HAVE
ANNOUNCED.
Q..
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WOULD DID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER ITEM OR.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MISTER DAILY.
FOLLOWED BY MS CABALLERO EGGMAN.
CHEN MISTER GARCIA.
AND WE HAVE A REQUEST FROM
MISTER KALRA THAT WILL NOT
AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
I WON'T TARA HAVE PRETEND THAT
MY REQUEST IS A.
IT'S AS IMPORTANT AS THE
PREVIOUS AND NEVERTHELESS A.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO. THE DISTRICT
I SERVE.
SANTA ANA REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION CENTER WAS BUILT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
SINCE THAT TIME THE CITY OF
SANTA ANA HAS ADOPTED THE
TRANSIT ZONING CODE IN A STATION
DISTRICT MASTER PLAN WHICH HAS
SPURRED DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ADJACENT NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS PARTICULAR TRAIN STATION IS
A VITAL REGIONAL INTERMODAL
TRANSIT HUB.
BRINGING TOGETHER AMTRAK
METROLINK ORANGE COUNTY TRANSIT
AUTHORITY BUS SERVICES AND TAXI
SERVICES IN ONE LOCATION.
IT IS THE COUNTY SEAT OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
AN ESTIMATED THREE THOUSAND
COMMUTERS PASSED THROUGH THE
CENTER EVERY DAY A NUMBER WHICH
IS EXPECTED TO RISE.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE AS RAIL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
INCREASE.
THIS IS A TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST
TO HELP THE CITY RESTORE.
THE STATION ITSELF AND A FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT SPACE THAT
IS CURRENTLY VACANT IN THE
STATION.
PROJECT IS IS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATE'S DESIRE TO BOOST
RIDERSHIP ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND ENCOURAGE
MORE TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
CASEY ELLIOTT WHO REPRESENTS THE
CITY OF SANTA ANA.
Q. SEALY IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN AND I WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUDGET IS
VERY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING NONE.
MS CABALLERO THANKS AGAIN THANK
YOU SIR.
YEAH BUT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER I THINK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT ON THIS
BUDGET. REQUEST
A CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS SHARE
A GREAT AGRICULTURAL HISTORY
WE FEED THE NATION AND THE
PLANET WITH OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SPECIALTY CROPS THAT CAN ONLY BE
GROWN IN OUR UNIQUE CLIMATE.
THESE BUDGET REQUEST WILL ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA FARMERS RANCHERS
DAIRY MEN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO THRIVE WITH THE SAFE
SUSTAINABLE HIGH PRODUCING AN
ECONOMICALLY VALUABLE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
BY INVESTING AGRICULTURE CAT
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE NATION
AND THE WORLD IN AG TECHNOLOGY
START UPS VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING AND OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES WILL SEE NEW TECH
JOBS KEEPING INTELLECTUAL
CAPITAL IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES SUFFER FROM
A BRAIN DRAIN AT ITS BEST AND
BRIGHT BRIGHTEST URBAN JOB
CENTERS.
FIRST WE MUST ACT QUICKLY TO
ADEQUATELY FUND PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THE ECONOMIC SAFETY OF A
HUGE INDUSTRY.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE CROPS
DECIMATED BY AM INVASIVE PESTS
LIKE FLORIDA DID.
I ASKED FOR A BUDGET ITEM OF
FORTY FIVE MILLION TWO CD A
PHASE INVASIVE PLANT AND PEST
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS IN OTHER
WORDS THAT WOULD. INCLUDE THE
BAR OR.
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTES TARIFFS CONSTRICTING
OUR EXPORT MARKETS I SEEK FUNDS
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE
CALIFORNIA GROWN MARKETING
AGREEMENT.
CHORUS RELY ON OUR LAND GRANT
INSTITUTIONS FOR APPLIED
RESEARCH AND ADVISORY SERVICES.
A BUDGET OF TEN MILLION ANNUALLY
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES DIVISION TO HIRE AND
RETAIN COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
EXPERT ADVISORS WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTIONS TO
COMPETE IN THIS. BASICALLY WOULD
RESTORE THESE.
THESE ACT.
EXPERTS THAT HAVE BEEN.
REDUCED OVER THE YEARS.
SMALL FARMERS MISSPENT HOURS
EVERY MONTH AWAY FROM THEIR
BUSINESS TO IT NAVIGATE THE
LABYRINTH OF DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCY WEBSITE IN ORDER TO FILL
OUT FORMS.
AB THIS REQUEST SIX ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO CDFA FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A CENTRALIZED AG
BUSINESS PORTAL. WERE ALL
REPORTING AND REGULATORY
INFORMATION FROM ANY STATE
AGENCY WILL LIVE IN ONE ONLINE
LOCATION.
AND BECAUSE IT ADVANCED IMPLANT
ECONOMIC MODEL OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY INDICATES
THAT THE TOTAL IMPACT IS UP TO
SIX HUNDRED BILLION ANNUALLY OF
THE TWO POINT SIX TRILLION GDP.
ON THIS REQUEST SEEKS TO PROVIDE
FUNDS TO THE M. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO
PRODUCE THEIR OWN IMPLANT.
FARM TO FORK ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS.
SECOND WE MUST INVEST TO CREATE
A STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA AG TECH
INNOVATION PLATFORM. AG TECH IS
A YOUNG INDUSTRY THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR WEALTH CREATION IN RURAL
AREAS THROUGH AG TECH ISRAEL IF
CALIFORNIA CAPTURES VENTURE
VENTURE CAPITAL DOLLARS AND IS
HOME TO ACT TECH INNOVATORS AND
START UP COMPANIES.
MAKE SURE THE CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE WORLD IN AG TECH INVESTING
IN ENTREPRENEURS THIS REQUEST IS
FOR TWENTY MILLION TWO CD OF
PAY.
TO DEVELOP THE AGRICULTURE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION INSTITUTE
ON THIS WOULD BE ONE OF SIX AND
TO INSTITUTES THAT ARE ALREADY
LOCATED AT THE UC.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
DIVISION.
PERHAPS JUST AS IMPORTANTLY I
REQUEST THAT FUTURE BUDGETS
INCLUDE AN INCENTIVE TAX CREDIT
TO ADOPT ADOPTERS OF
AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY WHEN
DEPLOYED ON IRRIGATED ACRES WITH
THE GOAL TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES AND ENERGY. WATER
FERTILIZER PESTICIDE USE OR TO
AUTOMATIC PLANTING THINNING
HARVESTING AND PRODUCTION
SERVICES.
THIS ACT TECH CREDIT MODEL
FOCUSES OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE CREDITS TO FARMERS UNDER A
THOUSAND ACRES WHICH IS ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THE
HARVESTED ACREAGE. AND MAY HAVE
A HARDER TIME OVERCOMING THE
OPERATIONAL CAPITAL COST TO
ADAPT ACT TECHNOLOGY WERE
BASICALLY ASKING FARMERS TO
PRODUCE MORE WITH LESS AND THIS
GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO ADAPT TO THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND AND AND ACTUALLY
UP AND BRING IT UP TO SCALE.
THIRD BY EDUCATING CALIFORNIA'S
RURAL YOUTH SO THEY CAN MANAGE
IT OPERATE OUR FARMS OF THE
FUTURE WE PROVIDE THE ROOT FOR
RURAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO FILL THESE NEW
ACTING CHOPS.
SMART FARMS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WILL BE ACT TECH SHOWCASES WERE
SMALL GROUPS WITH THE HOW TO
JUMP THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND
STUDENTS WILL FIND REAL WORLD
CAREER PATH PATHWAYS.
AG TECH WORK COURSEWORK WILL
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED MORE DEEPLY
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
SYSTEM AND.
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE STATE.
JOBS ON THE FARM WILL CHANGE AS
PRECISION AND AUTOMATED AG
EXPANDS.
THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA FARM
WORKER IT'S OVER FIFTY FIVE AND
THE LABOR POOL IS SHRINKING.
THERE WILL BE FEWER AND FEWER
JOBS IN THE FIELD HIGHER PAYING
JOBS REQUIRING THE ABILITY TO
MANAGE AND INTEGRATE WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND THAT MEANS RURAL
KIDS WILL NOT HAVE TO MOVE TO
THE SILICON VALLEY TO WORK IN
TECH.
I'M I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TOUR FARMS ALL OVER THE STATE
AND IT'S INCREDIBLE THE AMOUNT
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT IS BEING
UTILIZED AND WE REALLY NEED TO
TRAIN THE WORKFORCE.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T THESE JOBS
WILL BE TAKEN BY OTHER.
STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE REALLY AGGRESSIVE TECH.
AB STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE TO
COME IN AND AND DEPLOY ON AND
AND ACTUALLY WORK THE SYSTEM.
I AM ASKING FOR SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN STATE AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES CRITICAL ADVISORY
SERVICES AND REGULATORY
PROTECTION FOR STEMS THE
INVESTMENT WILL YIELD
GREAT RETURNS FOR THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AND RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR. AND MARRIES TO OF
CALIFORNIA'S STRONGEST
INDUSTRIES WITHOUT TAKING BOLD
STEPS THE INDUSTRY WILL LACK THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE TO
MEET THE MASSIVE MODERNIZATION
CHALLENGES WHICH ARE BEING
DRIVEN. BY THE STATE'S
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT BY
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AND TRADE
POLICIES AND BY OUR OWN NEED TO
FEED A HUNGRY WORLD. THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
INCLUDING THESE REQUESTS IN THE
BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNSEL AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION LARA
KNOWLEDGE HINGED ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN
SUPPORT OF LOOKING AND MOURN
INTO INVASIVE SPECIES IN
AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARY ON WARMER DOWN
THE ROAD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MS EGGMAN.
DOCTOR EGGMAN PARDON.
SEASONS FINE. A GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY.
.
IS BUTANE TO GRF FUNDS AND OVER
THE YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS CREATE
AMBITIOUS SOCK CLIMATE AND WASTE
DIVERSION REQUIREMENTS.
TWO YEARS AGO THIS LEGISLATURE
TO HELP THE PASS SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR LARA
WHICH REQUIRES A STATE REDUCE
METHANE EMISSIONS BY DIVERTING
THREE QUARTERS. OF THE ORGANIC
WAY SENT TO LANDFILLS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
ORGANIC WASTE CONTINUES TO MAKE
UP ONE THIRD OF OUR WASTE STREAM
AND FOOD CONTINUES TO BE THE
BIGGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF ITEMS
DISPOSE.
ORGANIC WASTE LANDFILLS APPROX
IT REDUCES APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
MILLION TONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
EVERY YEAR.
CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROPERLY
HANDLE OTHER ORGANIC WASTE WE
GENERATE. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
WE NEED BETWEEN FIFTY AND A
HUNDRED LARGE SCALE FACILITIES
WILL BE NEEDED TO MEET THE
GOALS.
THAT WE SET OUT IN S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT.
INVESTMENT IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF COMPOSTING FACILITIES
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION HERBS.
AND OTHER RECYCLING OUTLETS TO
PROCESS THIS WASTE.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BUDGET
REQUEST ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GO TO COUNT
RECYCLE FROM G. GRF FUNDS. AND
THIS WILL BE USED ON PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
TO WAGE REDUCTIONS COMPOSTING
RECYCLE CONTENT. MANUFACTURING
AND EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY.
THIS IS A A A REQUEST TO USE A
POLICIES WE PASSED TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE GASSES TO BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR. OUR VALUES AND OUR BILLS I
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT CONSIDERATION FOR THIS
FUNDING REQUEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE ASK WAS ALSO ASKED TO
EXPRESS THE SPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. AND THE NUMEROUS FOOD
BANKS THAT ARE THE MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIR NUMBERS
VINCE WORK MUCH WITH THE VITAMIN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NOT DOUBLE
RESOURCE RECOVERY IT'S PART OF
THE BUDGET ASK.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORUS I'M CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE IN JOHN WICK
FOUNDER OF MARIN CARBON PROJECT
IN SUPPORT THINKING.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLIO TO BE
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL THIS ALWAYS
ASSOCIATION NORTH AMERICAN SPORT
THINKING.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THERESA BREAKAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION
AND THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAPPING LENDS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
REFUGE OF RECYCLING COUNCIL IN
THE ASSOCIATION A COMPOST
PRODUCERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
REALLY APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN
THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR CHEN.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND FOR
PER YEAR FOR TWO REQUESTS.
DOCTOR WORKING ARE REQUESTING
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
FOR THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO
BE MISS RIDGES STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. IMPROVE
THE DRINKING WATER QUALITY
RESIDENTIAL HOMES.
THE FUNDS WILL BE USED AS OUT
YOU GRAB PROGRAM PROVIDE LOW
INTEREST LOANS TO PROPERTY
OWNERS FOR THE PLACEMENT OF
QUIRK RHODEN OR LET CONTAINING
PLUMBING. ADVERSELY IMPACT THEIR
DRINKING WATER.
IN RECENT YEARS HAVE REPORTS OF
DISCHORD HER AND LET CONTINUE
PIPES AND FIXTURES DEPRIVED
HOMES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY OF CARD
YOU KNOW EXPERIENCING
DISCOLORATION ODOR OF DRINKING
WATER IN THEIR HOMES.
THE WATER FROM THE FAUCET WAS
BLACK CANNOT BE USED TO COOK
CLEAN OR EVEN TO DRINK.
THE BOMB WAS CAUSED BY AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING PIPES.
THAT NEEDED TO BE REPLACE TWO
YEARS LATER IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE U. S. EPA INVESTIGATOR
REPORTS OF DISCORD WATER IN THE
CITY OF FRESNO.
THIS TIME THE ISSUE CAME FROM
CORROSION FOUND IN IMPROPER
GALVANIZE PIPES WERE LOOKING
TAINING FISHERIES ARE USED TO
BUILD THESE PROPERTIES IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND TWO
THOUSANDS.
PARTS OF NORTH EAST FRESNO HAD
WATER SAMPLES TESTED LOW LEVELS
OF WHAT THE FEDERAL THRESHOLD
REQUIRED CORRECTIVE ACTIONS.
CITIES WORK WITH HOMEOWNERS TO
ENCOURAGE CHANGES UPON THE OTHER
POPPING.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY OTHER FEW
TO NO PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO
SYSTEM PLUMBING MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS. AIMED AT IMPROVING
WATER QUALITY ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
THIS YOU MAY WANT TO STILL BE
INFECTED BY THE LARGEST TOXIC
CLEANUP AND IT'S KIND IN
CALIFORNIA.
THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN LA COUNTY
RETAIN IT WOULD LEAD IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PREDOMINANTLY IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN PROPERTY AND POVERTY.
IN A SAMPLE OF SEVEN THOUSAND
HOMES MORE THAN NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT SHOWED. LEAD LEVELS
ABOVE CALIFORNIA HOLES TEARS OF
RESIDENTIAL SLOW EIGHTY PARTS
PER MILLION.
MAY THESE PROPERTY OWNERS COME
FOR HIGHER INTEREST PRIVATE
LOANS FOR THESE PURPOSES.
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY FINDING
LAWSUIT AGAINST EXIDE
TECHNOLOGIES IN LA COUNTY AS
THEY CONTINUE TO DOLLARS
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY.
MILLIONS OF SERVICE LINES ARE
ONLY DE RESPONSIBLY THE CITY OF
TO THE PROPERTY LINE AT WHICH
POINT RESPONSIBLY FALLS ON THAT
PROPERTY OWNER.
THIS POSES OF YOUR HEALTH PRESS
RISK THROUGHOUT TE STATE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT LOW
INCOME REACHES MORE SEVERELY.
WHERE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME AND THEY CAN BE STAFF
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS ITEM?
THIS CONCLUDES THIS PARTICULAR
REQUEST IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR
PLACE.
MY SECOND BUDGET REQUEST IS.
.
HOPING TO HAVE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER IS TO AN EIGHTY
THOUSAND FOR THE GENERAL FUND
THE DEPARTMENT PARKS RECREATION
FOR THE TRAVIS RANCH YOU'VE PARK
YOUR CREATION REPLACEMENT
PROJECT IN YORBA LINDA. THIS IS
PERSONALLY HIGH PRIORITY
PROJECTS FOR MY CONSTITUENTS.
THE PROJECT WAS APPROVED BY YOUR
BELINDA CITY COUNCIL IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN. THE
CITY DOES NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO COMPLETE A PROJECT AT
THIS TIME.
THE PUTTING CLUES INSTALLATION
OF NEW IRRIGATION MAINLAND AND
LATERAL LINES NEW IRRIGATION
CONTROL VALVE BOXES IN NEW
ENVISIONED HEADS AND ALL
NECESSARY CONNECTIONS AND
FITTINGS TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT.
FEDERATION SYSTEM TRAVIS RANCH
YOU'VE PARK.
WAS ASSAULT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. THEIR CREE ORIGINATION
VALVE BOXES OUR PLACE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PLAYING FIELD
GREENHOUSE ARE SPLIT PLAYING
CONDITIONS.
DEVELOPMENT ZONE IMPROPERLY
IRRIGATION COVER TO SUPPORT AND
THE VALVE IS ONLY.
I DO NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT SHAPE
PATTERNS ELEVATION DIFFERENCES.
TRAVIS RANCH YOU PARK IS A HAVE
WE USE PARK THAT IS LOCATED
ADJACENT TO TRAVIS RASH
ELEMENTARY CONTRIVED FRENCH
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
AND PARK ESSENTIALLY CADENCE IN
YORBA LINDA AND IS HOME TO THE
EAST HILLS LITTLE LEAGUE ZERO
UNITED SOCCER SOLUTION OTHER
SPORTS YOU'VE WEEKS.
THE PARK RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY.
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
VISITORS EACH YEAR INCLUDING
DAILY ACCESS BY RESIDENTS SPORTS
LEAGUES AS STUDENTS FROM
ADJACENT SCHOOLS.
THE NEW IRRIGATION SYSTEM WILL
BE FIFTY PERCENT MORE EFFICIENT
WAY TO WATER STAINS AND SEE FOR
PLAN CONDITIONS FOR THE CHILDREN
ACT WE PLAY IN THIS PARK.
RENOVATING THE IRRIGATION SYSTEM
WITH CURRENT WATER SAVING
TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDE DRIP
IRRIGATION WATER SERIES ENHANCE
AND IMPROVE THE WATER FIRST OF
THE SPORT. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME.
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING
ME ON THIS ON THESE TWO ITEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
SAYING NO QUESTIONS IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. PARTNER EITHER
MR CHAN'S ITEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIGURES FOR
COMMUTERS NEXT UP WE HAVE MISTER
GARCIA. WELCOME.
IT MONNING MISTER CHAIR INTO
COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK TO YOU THIS MORNING ABOUT
A COLLECTIVE REQUEST THAT THAT'S
BEEN MADE. BY.
FIFTEEN OF OUR COLLEAGUES FOR
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
THIS PROPOSAL WAS BASED ON OF
MATH THAT SHOWED APPROXIMATELY
FOUR NEW FIFTY MILLION. SURPLUS
FROM LAST YEAR'S EXPENDITURE
PLAN. AND THE LA OZONOLYSIS THEY
SHOWED IN APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED SURPLUS IN THE FUND. IF
THE ADMINISTRATION CHEN YOUR
PROPOSAL IS ADOPTED.
I RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT TO EMPTY THE
FUNDING TERRIBLY EVERY YEAR. AND
THAT THERE ARE OTHER. IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ISSA REALITY AND DATA THAT'S THE
REALITY AND WHILE THE JURY IF
HAS GENERALLYCOLLECT THE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
THERE WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH.
MONEY TO FULLY FUND ALL OF OUR
PRIORITIES.
AND MY OPINION THE QUESTION THE
TABLE IS HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE. THAT
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED URGENTLY NEEDS WERE
ALSO PLANNING FOR OTHER
INCENTIVES AND REGULATIONS. CAN
PASS.
AND BE SUPPORTED ABOUT TO REACH
THOSE GOALS.
SO LIKE TO POST A SLIGHT
REVISION TO OUR EARLIER REQUEST.
A MODEST A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE NATURAL
BY AND WORKING LANCE PROGRAMS.
THE GRE A FUN AT BEFORE YOU HAVE
A LETTER AND A BREAKDOWN.
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS EVERYTHING
FROM THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD.
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL URBAN
FORESTRY PROGRAM THE URBAN GREEN
PROGRAM WETLANDS IN WATERSHEDS
RESTORATION PROGRAM.
THIS WE PROGRAM HEALTHY SOILS IT
THAT WE KNOW ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO OUR A COMMUNIY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
ALL THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
CRITICAL BENEFITS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FOUR AND. A
TO ADDRESSING THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. OFFER THIS
COLLECTIVE QUEST.
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS STEVE
BAKER WITH THEIR NEW ILLNESSES
HITS FOR THE RESOURCES LEGACY
FUND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMAN
GARCIA IS ABILITY TO BRING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY TOGETHER
ON THIS.
AND YOUR SUPPORT.
MORNING DANIELLE INCH ON BEHALF
OF THAT CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS THE
OCEAN CONSERVANCY. ALLEY
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST FUNDS OF
THE LA RIVER AND COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTIONS SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIA'S FRONT SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ON FOUR OF THEM ON
BEHALF OF US SOON HOUSE ONE
SUPPORT A STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MATTER.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BRIAN SHOWED CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK ALSO
STRONG SUPPORTER THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS NATIONAL WORKING AND
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND LISA PARA
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
TWENTY CHUCKLES A CALIFORNIA
RELIEF ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO GANDHI IN YORK WITH
VIOLENCE CONSERVANCY ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PUBLIC AREAS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MARK FENCED MAKER FOR AMOUNTS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY THE MOHAVE DESERT LAND
TRUST IN THE CALIFORNIA TOP
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE FOREST'S
COUNCILS SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE AUTHORITY AND SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LUCAS FRERICHS ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING RECALL MONSTER
DONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD WORK OF THE STAFF IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER COCKY WITH
PENCIL OPEN SPACE TRUST AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TASCHEN NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT.
RIGHT DOWN WITH THE LOS ANGELES
BEAUTIFICATION TEAM IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARC SMITH ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TROUT THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION. AND THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PAUL MASON WITH PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE ASSEMBLY'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M ALEX HARVEY
AREA WITH FRIENDS THE URBAN
FOREST IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ROSE EPPERSON WESTERN CHAPTER
INTERNATIONAL SOCIETY OF ARBOR
CULTURE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS EFFORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF THE CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT.
CAN NIGHT YOUR CHILDREN'S TREES
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND A TROTTER WITH WEST COAST
ARBORISTS ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY.
TRUNKS.
LEE HEIRS WHO TREE FRESNO AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU MISTER
GARCIA.
I APPRECIATE A PRESENTATION ON
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT. AND TO OUR
NEXT PRESENTER IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER.
YOU NEXT MISTER HOLTON.
LITTLE OVER ANXIOUS THERE.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
.
THE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU ON A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON
THE ISSUE OF DAM SAFETY.
BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT REALLY KEEPS ME UP AT
NIGHT.
AND THAT I THINK I SHOULD
REALLY CONCERN ALL OF US IS THE
CHANCE OF A DEVASTATING FLOOD
AND A LEVEE BREAK IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A VERY REAL.
POSSIBILITY EVEN IN THIS LAST
TIME.
WINTER SEASON.
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WINTER
SEASON WE ALMOST HAD A WE HAD AN
UNDERMINE A LEVEE NEXT TO YUBA
CITY.
CITY OF SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
HAD THAT LEVY.
HAVE BEEN BREACHED.
.
NO SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE'S
LIVES PROPERTY I WOULD HAVE BEEN
WOULD HAVE BEEN AT RISK AND
THIS.
THIS RISK IS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
CALIFORNIA'S LEVEES AND FLOOD
CONTROL INFRASTRUCTURE WAS GIVEN
A DEGRADING. AB BY THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CIVIL ENGINEERS. AND
IF YOU KNOW.
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY FLOOD.
HAS BEEN PART OF OUR HISTORY
HAS BEEN.
YA SINCE ITS FOUNDING AL WE
HAVE FACED THE PROSPECT AND HAVE
BEEN.
BATTLING.
THE INLAND SEA AS IT'S CALLED.
.
AND YOU KNOW EVEN.
LELAND STANFORD I REMIND PEOPLE
WENT TO HIS INAUGURATION HERE AT
THE CAPITOL BY BOAT BECAUSE
SACRAMENTO WAS FLOODED. AND AT
THE TIME.
AND SO THERE'S A VERY REAL.
ISSUE HERE THAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURES BECOME.
DEFICIENT.
IN IN NEED OF REPAIR IN NEED OF
UPGRADE.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING IN THE INVESTMENT
TO DO SO SO I'VE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED. AN ANNUAL
APPROPRITION OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE STATE BUDGET.
TO ALLOCATED TOWARDS THE STATE'S
FLOOD CONTROL INFRASTRUCTURE NOW
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO.
NEAR WE NEED TO HAVE BETTER
SETTLEMENT.
MANAGEMENT IN IN OUR FLOOD WAYS
THAT SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
AND BUT ONE OF THE BIG THINGS IS
JUST DEALING WITH THESE CRITICAL
REPAIRS TO LEVEES.
.
AND YOU KNOW BY HAVING THIS
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION WE CAN
REALLY START TO GET AT SOME OF
THE. YOU KNOW THE MOST
PROBLEMATIC AREAS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
NEAR THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
PLAN IDENTIFIED.
THE NEED TO INVEST SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE BILLION OVER THE NEXT
THIRTY YEARS.
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
TO ADDRESS IN TERMS OF CAPITAL
PROJECTS.
BUT I LOOK AT THIS HUNDRED
MILLION AS JUST YOUR BASIC ANA.
OF ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S BEING TAKEN
CARE OF.
ONE THING THAT I PROPOSES
EITHER A CONTINUOUS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION OR IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE. AT LEAST
MAYBE DOING A ONE TIME FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION THIS YEAR.
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG THERE'S
IT AND NDW ARE HAS TESTIFIED
THAT THERE'S A HUGE BACKLOG IN
REPAIRS THAT NEED TO GET. AT
THAT NEED TO GET DONE.
SEVERAL HOT HOT SPOTS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THIS IS A LARGER ISSUE THAN
JUST ONE COUNTY OR ONE DISTRICT
THIS AFFECTS ALL CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE FORMED IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THE SENATE A FLOOD CONTROL
CAUCUS THAT'S TWENTY NINE
MEMBERS.
AND WE ARE MAKING THAT REQUEST
ON BEHALF OF THE CAUCUS.
WE HAVE.
EIGHTEEN MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SIGNED ON TO.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
BY MAKING THIS INVESTMENT NOW
WE CAN SAVE LIVES PROPERTY. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SAVE THE
STATE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WHICH
IS ANOTHER THING I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT BECAUSE OF THE
PATERNAL CASE.
A FEW YEARS BACK THE STATE IS
LIABLE IF ONE OF THESE LEVEES
BREAKS AND CAUSES DAMAGE TO
LIVES AND PROPERTY. I'M A
BELIEVE THE LAST KNOWS NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX.
THAT WE WERE FOUND LIABLE FOR
UNDER THE PATERNAL CASE.
THAT BELIEVE THE NUMBER THERE
WAS SOME AROUND FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS THE
STATE WAS FOUND LIABLE FOR.
IF IT HAPPENS TODAY WE'RE
TALKING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE CAN POTENTIALLY BE LIABLE FOR
SO. MAKING AN INVESTMENT NOW
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND I WOULD
ASK THE.
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THIS
REQUEST.
AGAIN IF.
EITHER AS A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION OR AT LEAST TRYING
TO ADDRESS AND IN A SIGNIFICANT
WAY THE BACKLOG OF REPAIRS
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT.
WENDY RIGOROUS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE AWKWARD AND STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS WE ALSO TESTIFIED
IN THE SENATE SUB. TO COMMITTEE
ON THIS VERY SAME ITEM AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MARK SMITH THEM WE HAVE A NOR
FOR GOD'S SPORTSMAN'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO THE GOLDEN GATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION COULD BE HERE
TODAY JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT A
SMALL THING THAT THE ASSEMBLYMAN
MENTIONED WERE JUST SETTLEMENT.
WHICH MEANT QUICKLY ON THE
FEATHER RIVER WHICH IS SUFFERING
THE CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER THE OROVILLE
INCIDENT AND PRIOR TO THAT AS
WELL. WE WOULD THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BETTER AND ONE WILL
NEVER PAY THE SAME RULES.
THANK YOU.
SURE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB READ
WITH READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL
ASSOCIATION SUTTER BUTTE FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY AND THE TULARE
RIVER. IMPROVEMENT JPA IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEMBERS REQUEST.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROBERT SPIEGEL
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MR CARE MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FUNG.
I USUALLY OF OF IT WILL BE VICE
WHAT I THINK IS IN THE GALLAGHER
FOR BEING A LEADER ON THIS
CRITICAL CRITICAL ISSUE.
THE NEAR CRISIS WE FACE A NOVEL
DOWN WAS A CLEAR WAKE UP CALL
THAT WE NEED TO INVEST.
FOR THE FUTURE WE CAN'T DELAY.
IN WAIT FOR THE NEXT Y.
SITUATION SO THIS IS A WISE
INVESTMENT.
TO PROTECT OUR LEVEES AND TO
PROTECT OUR STATE TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IS NEXT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GALLAGHER THINKERS UNIT.
ORDER MR CHAIRMAN MARTIN MEDI.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE
YOU TODAY AND PRESENT MY REQUEST
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
IS TO HELP OUR STATE PROMOTE
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP.
AND PROVIDE A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR.
FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOUR
DISCOUNTED TRANSIT PASS PROGRAM
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
THIS WOULD BE FUNDING FOR
STUDENT TRANSIT PASS PILOT
PROGRAM.
THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
WHAT FOSTER NEW GENERATION OF
TRANSIT USERS HELP UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AND REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF CARS ON THE ROAD.
THE PROGRAM WILL ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS TO PARTNER
WITH TRANSIT REGIONAL TRANSIT
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP INNOVATIVE
STUDENT TRANSIT PROGRAMS.
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT AND THOSE
THAT SERVE MY DISTRICT ARE
BEGINNING TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS.
BUT WITHOUT DOUBT MORE HELP IS
NEEDED TO FILL IN THE GAPS.
WHILE THE STUDY WILL BE
CONDUCTED BY TWENTY TWENTY
THANKS TO AB TWENTY THREE OH FOR
AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. WE
MUST TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION EFFORTS
AND INCREASE THE POOL TRANSIT
USERS. TO RELIEVE THE PRESSURE
ON OUR ROADS AND OUR CLIMATE.
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS ALL CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST AND IF I
COULD.
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE TO.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO TURN THE
REST OF MY TIME OVER TO IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE DENNY'S AND
ENJOY STARK.
NEWS THAT WE PROBLEM YOU HAVE.
.
WILL KALITTA TWO MINUTES SENATE
REMAINING OF UTILITY COMMITTEES
ARE.
YES
THANK YOU MISTER IS ANGELES A.
YES HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH TIME
THAT HE'S AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MOVE LA.
WE THINK THIS REQUEST HOLDS THE
POTENTIAL FOR REALLY UNLEASHING
A TREMENDOUS ON NEW RIDERSHIP
OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ON WE ESTIMATE
FOR EXAMPLE THE POTENTIAL IN LOS
ANGELESCOUNTY ALONE. IS
RIDERSHIP GROWTH EQUAL TO THAT
OF THE RED LINE.
AT A FRACTION OF THE COST ON
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WITHOUT SPENDING SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TO BUILD A NEW REDLINE
IT'S A DRAMATIC OPPORTUNITY WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I DIDN'T.
GOOD MORNING ALMOST AFTERNOON
AYE JOSHUA STARK STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH TRANSFORM.
ALL ALL DISTAFF.
OFFER ME TOO BECAUSE I KNOW
THINGS HAVE BEEN MOVING QUITE A
BIT BUT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SPEAKING WITH YOU ALL.
ABOUT THAT I MEAN AT THE BILL
THE AT THE REQUEST AND LOOK FOR
TO SPEAKING WITH YOU ABOUT THE
MATTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TESLIN GEL I AM WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST AND
REVERSIBLE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
BASED ON PINE. OUTCOMES AND
SUCCESSES OF A PILOT PROGRAM
WERE DOING AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TERRORISTS  WITH
THAT CAL STATE SOON ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CSU STUDENTS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS REQUEST
THANK YOU.
RECALL MOTHRA NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLTON THANK
YOU HI TOALL WHO HAVE ADDED
YOUR COMMENTS AND WE HAVE ONE
REMAINING REQUEST.
A FROM A MEMBER OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
LASSEN LEGISLATURE PASS SP FOUR
NINETY TWO FROM SENATOR BALLOT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THE BILL SHE MINDS ABILITY FOR
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS MID
PAN TO PURCHASE SOME PROTECT
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED ACRES. OF
CRITICAL WATERSHED LAND OWNED BY
THAT SOUNDS A WATER COMPANY.
THE BILL IS IN EFFECT FOR FIVE
YEARS ON RESPECTFULLY ASK
POTENTIALLY DOLLARS TO BE
ALLOCATED FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARDS HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. TOWARD THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SP FOUR NINETY
TWO.
THIS BUDGET REQUESTS ALONG WITH
THE I DON'T CALL REQUEST BY
SENATOR JIM BELL WILL ENSURE
THAT THE SOUNDS A REGIONAL BE
ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
THE GROWING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND MAINTAIN ITS BATTLE
GROUND WATER SUPPLY.
BASED ON ROUGH ESTIMATES THE
LAND HAS BEEN PRELIMINARILY
VALUED AT FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. MADE PAN MAY BE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE AS MUCH AS TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION TOWARDS THE.
I POSITION BUT THAT STILL LEAVES
A SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GAP TO
FILL. MID PENN IS ENGAGING WITH
FUNDING PARTNERS THE FUNDING
FROM THE STATE WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO MAKE THIS DEAL HAPPEN.
THIS REQUEST AS A SPORT OPPOSE
SAMPLER COUNTY AND SURROUNDING
CITIES LIKE CERTAIN THE LOS
GATOS CAMPBELL AND SAN JOSE. AS
WELL AS IMPORTANT STATE AND
REGIONAL NONPROFITS THAT THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND COMMITTEE
FOR GREEN FOOTHILLS AND
GREENBELT ALLIANCE. THE LAND IS
IMPORTANT THE REGION AND MANY
WAYS IT INCLUDES OVER A THOUSAND
ACRES Y. BUT REDWOOD FORESTS.
A CRITICAL RESOURCE QUESTION
CARBON TO COUNTER A GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND IMPACTS.
TWICE IN THE RECENT PAST
ATTENTION MADE A LOT THE LAND
FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES MID PENN
HELP TO STOP THESE EFFORTS.
THE LAND IS THE SENATE AS A
PRIORITY CONSERVATION AREA BY
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT SEVERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND ALSO
PROVIDES CRITICAL REGIONAL
HABITAT CONNECTION TO THE DELTA
MOUNTAIN RANGE COYOTE VALLEY.
AND THE GOBLIN MOUNTAIN RANGE
THE SOUTH IN ADDITION THIS LAND
ALSO UNABLE IMPORTANT SEGMENT OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILE BAY
AREA WHICH TRAIL. WHICH SERVES
HIKERS MOUNTAIN BIKERS IN THE
QUESTIONS MACROSS REGION.
THE AREA HAS BEEN DESIGNATED AN
EXTRA AS AN EXTREME FIRE HAZARD
AS PART OF THE COUNTY ADOPTED
COMMUNITY ABOUT FIRE. PROTECTION
PLAN UNDER CALPERS FIRE HAS A
SEVERITY ZONE MAPS THESE
HOLDINGS CONSIDER PART OF THE
VERY HIGH VIRUS. IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA OF LAND
MANAGEMENT IS A CORE COMPETENCY
FOR MID PAN.
CURRENTLY MANAGES OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF PUBLIC OPEN
SPACE LANDS ADJACENT TO THIS
AREA AND I THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANALYTICS
ADORATION WAS.
THANK YOU LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
SOME FOLKS WHO LIKE DATA.
PHYLLIS TO SUPPORT THAT MODEST
RETURN MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
BEHALF OF THE SENATE CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THINKING OF.
REID ADDISON BEHALF AMID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SOCKS STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY INSTRUCTS.
RICCO MUST FOR THE NON A WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT.
Q. AND JUST UNDER THE WIRE IS
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A CLEAN
GETAWAY AND WHO SHOW UP AT.
WELL THANK YOU SIR FOR.
AND I HEAR ME OUT.
.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS MAY BE
THE LAST REQUEST BUT I'M HERE
NOW WITH THEIR MAYBE SOMEBODY
WITHOUT DOWN WHILE YOU'RE
TALKING YEAH RIGHT.
WELL I'M HERE TODAY TO US
SUPPORT TODAY. ARE A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM THAT HELPS OUR OUR
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL AS.
HELPS OUR OUR ENVIRONMENT
I'M ASKING FOR SUPPORT FOR A
BUDGET FUNDING REQUEST WHICH
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO
FUND THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
BUSINESS PROGRAM ON AN ONGOING
BASIS A LAST YEAR.
IN THE BUDGET.
BILL ONE MILLION WAS IT
APPROPRIATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION AGENCY
FOR THE PROGRAM UP BUT DOES THIS
IS DONE ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
THIS GREAT PROGRAM IT HELPS
SMALL BUSINESSES SAVE.
DOLLARS ON THEIR UTILITY COSTS
UP BY CUTTING DOWN. ON.
.
THERE ARE THEIR WATER USE THEIR.
WASTE REDUCTION INCREASED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND REDUCING GOTTA
THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDE SUPPORT
COUNSELLING IN IT AND ASSISTANCE
TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO THAT THEY BECOME THAT CAN
BECOME GREEN BUSINESS CERTIFIED.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OPERATED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
TO CERTIFY THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT VOLUNTARILY ADOPT
ENVIRONMENTALLY.
PREFERABLE BUILT BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
I'D SAY ON.
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR EFFORTS
TO.
.
IMPROVE OUR.
OUR ENVIRONMENT CUT DOWN ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT
TARGETS A CRITICAL AND
UNDERSERVED.
SECTOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH CONTRIBUTES SIGNIFICANTLY
OF COURSE.
TO OUR ECONOMY AS WELL AS.
.
TO.
OUR AIR QUALITY AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR JOE FLEMING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT TO.
PROVIDE FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR SMALL AND
MEDIUM BUSINESS SECTOR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER MERTZ ITCHY AND.
I THANK YOU ALL THISCONCLUDES
OUR LAST ITEM MARK CAVALCADE OF
MEMBER REQUESTS I'VE WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF REQUESTS.
THAT.
MEMBERS I HAVE SUBMITTED IN
WRITING THOSE WILL BE CONSIDERED
TO HAVE A ALONG WITH ALL OF THE
PRESENTATIONS REQUESTS AND
PRESENTATIONS OF INMATE TODAY SO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR. OF
PRESENTATIONS AND COMMENTS AND
WE ARE ADJOURNED